bonjour pour ce podcast probablement
aujourd'hui
j'accueille gilles mito de la chaîne
eureka qui est vraiment une excellente
chaîne grand un truc assez assez unique
dans son genre en économie et en
finances qui rentrent pas mal dans des
détails qui sont enfin là qui sont assez
annuaire area inhabituel de rentrer
autant dans les détails et c'est très
très très plaisant à chaque fois et puis
c'est aussi très drôle moi j'aime bien
l'humour de gilles docu bonjour ville
bonjour est ce que tu peux commencer par
un peu présenter ton parcours
comment est-ce que tu en est venu à
devenir youtuber en économie en finance
ok donc mon parcours j'ai un parcours
assez classique de d'école de commerce
j'ai fait un bac s j'ai fait une prépa
hec et puis après je suis allé en école
de commerce est en école de commerce je
trouvais que la finance était vraiment
si ce qui était le plus cool pour des
raisons
bref donc finances et puis je suis
rentré en banque d'investissement assez
rapidement par des stages et puis après
une fois que j'ai été diplômé et au bout
de obou de 7 ans en banque
d'investissement
j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion que en
fait c'est pas ça que je voulais faire
alors c'est un procès ce qui a mûri un
petit à petit mais l'idée c'est que je
cherchais à comprendre quel était mon
rôle dans la société
quand je travaillais en banque et quand
j'ai fini par avoir une image
suffisamment claire des choses j'ai pas
vraiment aimer le j'ai pas aimé vraiment
aimé le l'endroit où j'étais pouge
m'étais positionner quoi donc du coup la
question s'est posée de bon ben si c'est
pas ça qui plaît et si t'es pas bien là
qu'est ce que tu fais à la place et
voilà ce moment-là j'écoute est déjà pas
mal de chaînes de vulgarisation je
regardais un peu de tout je
m'intéressais beaucoup à la science et
et voilà pendant pendant mes études les
gens il aimait bien venir me demander
des conseils et tout parce que j'avais
quand j'avais compris quelque chose
arrive bien l'expliquer donc en mettant
un peu tout ça ensemble me suis dit
allez pourquoi pas essayer une chaîne
youtube
en plus il avait rien sur l'économie et
la finance je pense qu'il ya toujours
très peu de choses sur ces sujets là
donc voilà super donc tu as dit que tu
as trouvé la finance cool quand tu étais
en école de commerce
pourquoi pourquoi ce qui est cool alors
le la raison alors c'est toujours cette
source c'est toujours difficile
d'analyser un peu ce qui sait pas ce qui
s'est passé 1 j'ai du mal à savoir si
c'est si c'est moi qui rament yole qui
rationalisent ça comme ça maintenant
ou si c'est effectivement ce qui s'est
passé mais je pense que le truc c'est en
gros j'ai toujours fait un don de bac ès
sciences et tout scientifique
moi j'aimais bien la physique j'aimais
bien la biologie j'étais pas fort en
maths mais j'avais bien lu maths et puis
le client
et puis en prépa j'ai eu un super prof
de maths pendant une année c'était juste
exceptionnel il m'a fait comprendre
plein de trucs je me suis mis à adorer
les maths et du coup on arrivait en
école de commerce
on perd toute cette dimension un peu
scientifique on arrive dans des sujets
on va parler management on va parler
marketing on va parler ressources
humaines et ça ressemble à c'est pas ça
ressemble moins un truc ça ressemble à
des choses un peu intuitive quoi quand
tu vas au courant explique qu' il faut
faire si il faut faire ça tu dis ah oui
effectivement en bon genre sur le coup
tu y penses pas mais tu dis que tu
aurais pu y penser tout seul alors que
quand tu vas dans un cours de maths ou
dans un cours de physique tu dis ah
ouais la vache ça si on ne la prend pas
je peux pas le devinez quoi et la
finance sas avait ce coup là aussi la
finance avait ce bout là le goût du art
et si on la prend pas je peux pas le
deviner tout seul donc ça me trouvais
que c'était plus intéressant pour cette
raison là je pense voilà donc c'est pour
ça que je suis monsieur intérêt la
finance retrouver ce côté un peu
mathématiques physique je percevais ça
comme une science dure un peu tu as et
du cou
peut-être aussi dit que quand tu étais
déjà en finance dans le monde de la
finance et à penser à réfléchir à ta
place dans ta société dans la société
c'est comme ça que tout n'est venu à
questionner un peu ce que tu faisais
c'est bien ça ouais comment t'es venu
ses réflexions à ce que c'est commun
pour les gens dans la finance à la
sculpture est ce qu'il ya un truc en
particulier qui t'a poussé à réfléchir à
ça un peu votre question je n'ai jamais
pensé à ça pourquoi est ce que je me
suis posé ces questions là en fait je
pense qu'au début c'était une simple
question de curiosité c'est à dire
j'avais envie de comprendre alors
j'avais envie de comprendre si tu veux
moi je alors comment j'étais sur un
produit financier un peu particulier que
j'avais envie de comprendre vraiment
dans le détail parce que je me disais si
je veux rester dans l'équipe il faut que
voilà du coup je deviens un
professionnel du truc donc il faut
comprendre et en fait quand tu commences
à tirer la pelote de laine une question
en amène une autre qu'on amène une autre
et après c'est de la curiosité un peu
naturel une fois que tu as épuisé le la
question du produit financier sur lequel
tu te base tu dis mais du coup les mecs
qui achètent mon produit financier il
achète quoi d'autre en plus de mon
produit financier pour se couvrir par
exemple donc l'attend déduit qu'ils
achètent d'autres produits donc tu veux
comprendre comment ils fonctionnent
aussi ses autres produits adaptés partie
là dedans puis tu dis tiens mais c'est
qui les gens qui achètent ces produits
là et hop est alors du coup c'est qui
tous ces investisseurs d'où est-ce
qu'ils ont leur argent et habitudes et
zoom su faire c'est sans fin quoi donc
je pense que de lui c'était simplement
pour faire ma place dans l'équipe et
avoir suffisamment de connaissances pour
dire voilà vous voyez les gars le mot si
je suis un pro vous pouvez m'embaucher
et c'est devenu un c'est devenu une
question plus ah ouais mais là je suis
rendu suffisamment loin maintenant
maintenant la question c'est je veux
comprendre comment ça marche tout
l'ensemble par rapport aux autres
est-ce que les autres qui sont la
finance ont ce genre de réflexion c'est
une question que je me pose et
je me souviens avoir lu un livre d'un
mec qui est un journaliste qui alors son
truc à lui c'était de dire comment ça se
fait que les gens de la finance se
rendent pas compte de ce qu'ils ont
causés enfin il ya eu la crise de 2008
l'idée c'est qui est responsable fort
probablement une grande partie des
responsables sont financiers on va aller
parler à ses financiers là et on va voir
comment ils vivent le fait d'avoir été
responsable d'un cataclysme fin d'une
crise aussi énorme et en fait il ya des
mécanismes il trouve des mécanismes
assez normaux de gens qui dit non mais
c'est pas de ma faute
en fait comme tout le monde est
responsable d'une petite partie tout le
monde arrive à se dédouaner de la
responsabilité je pense que quelque part
il ya un peu de ça sert que les gens
commencent à dérouler la ficelle est un
moment donné ils disent oh là si je vais
plus loin dans mon analyse je vais pas
aimer les réponses ça commence là me
pointer le bout de son nez que je vais
pas aimer les réponses donc j'arrête le
raisonnement on va partir dans autre
chose maintenant je vais avoir des
enfants alors que je m'occupe de mes
enfants je vais vivre pour ma famille je
vais vivre pour mon voilà mon métier je
le vis comme un truc intéressant au
quotidien etc
mais voilà va pas trop non plus y est de
se poser des questions métaphysiques sur
la place dans le monde où ce genre de
choses cela s'était tu l'as eu cette
crainte
ben
en fait je les ai eus je les ai eus je
n'ai pas eu parce que pour moi j'avais
un peu l'année dans l'indus est l'idée
naïve de ok mais si je trouve un truc
qui me plaît pas c'est pas grave parce
que après l'idée c'est que je vais
progresser dans ce milieu là et je vais
le changer de l'intérieur tu vois ou un
truc comme ça des choses qui me place
pas quand j'aurai des postes de
responsabilité et machin truc je pense
que j'avais un peu ça dans l'arrière de
ma tête est à un moment donné j'ai un
ami à moi qui a fini par arrêter la
finance- aussi mais avec qui on
discutait de tout ça et lui il m'a dit
mais en fait tu es complètement
hypocrite là tu es en train de critiquer
un monde dans lequel tu évolues et voilà
qu'à un moment donné faut que tu sois
faut que tu sois en accord avec les
idées si tu penses vraiment ce que tu
viens de me dire faut que t'arrêtes la
finance et je crois que c'est lui le
premier qui m'a vraiment où j'ai été
obligé de me confronter avec la réalité
de hockey il faut peut-être que je pense
à faire autre chose il a encore fallu du
temps après pour que vraiment je passe à
autre chose qui est un peu ce cliché du
requin de la finance et qu'est ce que tu
penses de ces clichés
ouais alors en fait c'est un cliché
parce que en même temps c'est un truc
qui est quand même pas mal enseignée
quoi sert que honteux on t'explique même
dans l'est dans les salles des marchés
il ya un petit côté un petit côté non
mais c'est que c'est clairement c'est
clairement c'est clairement revendiqué
ces tirs
tu travailles pour une banque donc tu
fais partie d'une équipe alors je
généralise banques
ok ou d'un fonds d'investissement peu
importe tu travailles pour une
entreprise
ce qui compte c'est les bénéfices de
l'entreprise de ton entreprise de ton
équipe et même quand et traders c'est
encore plus restreint que ça c'est à
dire que on a beau essayer de te faire
croire qu'il ya un espèce de travail des
équipes on est tous dans la même banque
au final non il ya des desk voilà chaque
desk est responsable d'un produit
financier et on est tous en compétition
les uns avec les autres pour faire le
plus gros le plus gros bénéfice tu vois
donc
voilà donc tout de suite il ya cette
notion de compétition qui est très forte
vous demandez là c'est une course fois
réglé le premier faut donc voilà après
l'histoire de tous les coups sont permis
ben c'est pas tous les coups sont permis
il ya des règles voilà et au sein du
cadre enfin dans le cadre de ces règles
oui tu fais tu fais tout ce que tu veux
donc c'est ces voix là ça mène à des
comportements qui peuvent être
interprétées comme un peu des requins
mais ouais il ya de ça il ya clairement
de ça et est donc à l'étude qui raconte
que du coup à tapas et cette année c'est
ça dans la finance combien de temps il a
fallu pour pour avoir entre tes premiers
étaient première interrogation 407
moment où le tonton ami t'a fait
réfléchir et le monde tu as quitté plus
dans le milieu
alors il ya probablement c'est pas c'est
pas facile à dire c'est pas facile à
dire je dirais que plusieurs années quoi
peut-être deux ans trois ans un truc
comme ça c'est pas évident j'ai du mal à
situer le moment où mes recherches
étaient orientés vers comment fonctionne
le monde entre guillemets le moment où
j'ai passé ce cap là et le moment où
j'étais je cherche à me renseigner pour
devenir plus performant dans mon travail
et je sais plus quand est-ce que j'ai
c'est probablement pas une frontière qui
était si nette que ce à quoi cccc voilà
c'est intéressant que c'est du coup
s'exclame le fruit d'une longue
réflexion sur une longue période
ouais et après c'est probablement pas
aussi donc il ya du boulot tu peux pas y
penser tout le temps tu es pas
constamment en train de poser la
question non plus tu vois c'est des
choses qui reviennent comme ça c'est les
lectures petit à petit c'est youtube a
joué un rôle aussi parce que plus à
l'est je regardais des interviews des
dés
tu sais tu peux aller chercher
directement des gens qui t'ont plus un
moment donné qu'on dit un truc tu l'as
entendu cinq minutes est une [ __ ] lui
donner un intéressant
du coup tu va rechercher ce gars là et
puis tu trouves un peu tout ce qu'il
raconte et il ya je pense internet a
joué aussi un rôle tu vois ce n'est pas
le hasard de la télé qui m'a montré des
choses et des choses c'est un peu moi
qui ai puis à les sélectionner et puis
il ya le côté aussi moi je suis plus
maintenant je lis des livres et des
livres compliqué tout mais avant je
pense que j'étais moins capable de faire
ça est ce un des livres compliqué pense
que c'est d'être compliqué ça seront
teneurs en tout cas avant je peux pas
lire des livres que j'estime être
compliqué comme ça et pourquoi tu
pouvais pas avoir parce que tu manquer
de motivation
ouais probablement naughty propros
probablement de motivation et c'est pas
un voyage est un exemple il ya pas très
longtemps je me suis mis à lire un
bouquin écrit par un sociologue et un
philosophe
j'ai eu énormément de mal a commencé à
le lire ce livre parce que c'est écrit
d'une manière très différente de ce que
je lis d'habitude en économie ou en
finance c'est très c'est un style qui
est très littéraire et et petit à petit
dans livre je me suis mis à comprendre
la manière dont ça fonctionne et le
style et du coup je suis revenu au début
du livre est l'atout tous ces maires
tout s'éclaire c'est à dire que tu as
compris la première moitié du livre tu
vois j'avais beau le lire je ne
comprenais pas maintenant je suis revenu
en arrière et là c'est super chouette et
j'adore ce à quoi donc l'avant avant
ouais je ne sais pas expliquer trop
pourquoi je lisais plus des romans des
choses comme ça quoi c'était pas il y
avait un côté j'ai besoin de me divertir
quand je lis et pas de prendre la tête
tu as une finale je vois plus les
cheveux comme ça du tout pour moi c'est
pas me prendre la tête de d'apprendre un
truc mais bon j'ai perdu le fil de de la
question de départ du coût et du tout
coup quand tu as senti que tu voulais
arrêter la finance- savait comment t'as
fait la transition explique-t-elle
directement sur youtube après c'est ça
alors ouais en fait alors l'idée c'est
que je me suis retrouvé dans une
situation où
envoyé à new york et j'étais déjà en
train de me poser des questions sur la
finance est ce que je reste et ce que je
fais autre chose je ne me posais pas je
me disais pas du tout que j'allais faire
youtube je me disais que j'avais
peut-être plus faire du code des choses
comme ça il se trouve que avec un peu
mon expérience de ce que je faisais
j'avais appris à coder un petit peu je
me disais tiens ça ça me plaît bien il
faut peut-être que je me j'essaye de
bifurquer dans ce ver cette branche
et puis cette opportunité de partir à
new york pour faire un job vraiment bas
pas exactement de traders mais voilà le
même style quoi et là je me suis dit ok
donc ça c'est l'opportunité rêvée voilà
jusque là j'ai toujours été un petit peu
baladé d'un cdd un autre cdd ma position
n'était pas très clair mon rôle était
pas très clairement définis là ça y est
c'est un rôle très défini cadrés et tout
en plus à new york machin donc super on
tente l'expérience et au bout de deux
mois
là bas ça y est ça a fini 2 j'ai dit
d'accord donc ça c'était c'était
l'opportunité que j'attendais depuis
longtemps je déteste ça je déteste ça ne
va pas du tout du tout du tout et là il
ya tout tout tout et dégringoler dans la
tête sert que non seulement j'aime pas
ça alors il y avait un truc qui faisait
qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup d'activités
au moment où je suis arrivé
du coup samassa va encore plus ça va
encore moins plu mais me suis dit en
fait même s'il y avait de l'activité
j'aimerais pas faire ce que vers ce truc
là je trouve que c'est pas si utile que
ça je suis pas d'accord avec la
rémunération c'est pas d'accord avec le
l'ambiance générale est le rôle de la
que la banque s'est donné je suis
d'accord avec ray en plus de ça je pense
que je serai mauvais c'est rare que je
me disais même s'il y avait de
l'activité
et même si j'ai essayé de m'y mettre je
serai jamais un bon trader ou un bon
vendeur ou moins bon quoi que ce soit
parce que j'y crois pas donc ça ça
marchera pas quoi qu'il arrive faut
vraiment pas par poursuivre là dedans et
là le truc c'est que pour des raisons
voilages et j'étais obligé de rester
dans ce boulot au moins un an alors que
ça faisait deux mois que j'étais arrivé
donc il y avait dix mois à tenir et je
me suis dit il faut que je trouve un
truc à côté à faire quoi pour pour me
rattraper un peu branche parce que là
sinon je vais mal le vivre et la chaîne
youtube c'était cool parce que je
pouvais le faire le week end je pouvais
le faire le soir je peux le faire
voilà c'est comme ça que c'est venu et
puis après une fois que j'ai pu quitter
mon travail la chaîne youtube avait pas
non plus super démarrer mais c'était
quand même pas mal du coup tactique et
on travaille bout d'un an c'est voilà au
bout d'un an
et puis après je me suis dit bon on va
essayer de continuer un peu la chaîne
voir ce que ça peut donner
et puis voilà j'en suis toujours là
chaque à chaque année je me dis bon un
an de plus on verra ce que ça va donner
et du coup parce que la volonté à
londres d'un passing de temps à new york
un an un petit un tout petit peu plus
d'un an à new york et un retour à
londres
sachant que avant j'avais passé tout mon
temps à londres aussi en fait j'ai fait
toute ma carrière à londres à l'occasion
si tu pouvais revenir en arrière et
parler à toi du passé que ce soit toi
l'époque de l'école de commerce ou le
toit lorsque temps finiront sur toi
lorsque tu commences tu tues qu'est ce
que tu fais ce que tu dirais ça je
réfléchisse à sa beaucoup en ce moment
ouais alors qu'est ce que je pourrais
dire c'est pas facile parce que j'ai pas
l'impression que je pourrais convaincre
mon mois du passé que la finance n'est
pas forcément fait pour lui
ouais ouais parce que parce que je pense
que c'est c'est par l'expérience et
c'est forcément par l'expérience ça fait
trop envie c'est comme s'est passé comme
un sport que tu as envie d'essayer pitt
et ça y est tu aimes pas du tout s'il ya
quelqu'un qui vient dire à un homme et à
son thème rappaz tu comment tu peux être
convaincu par sa tu vas dire mais non
mais t'en servir l epita son je veux le
sentir je veux ressentir si j'aime ou si
j'aime par laisse-moi laisse moi faire
je crois que j'y arriverai jamais à
convaincre je pense pas que j'aurai
réussi à convaincre mon poids du passé
quoi qu'il arrive
par contre un truc que j'aurais
peut-être réussi à faire c'est essayer
de l'orienter vers certaines
connaissances que moi j'avais pas à
l'époque et que j'aurais pu avoir
donc certaines lectures
voilà sur les eaux - les prémices de
comment ça marche
ras tout le détail tout c'est un peu le
problème de l'école fin de la formation
qu'on a eu en école de commerce
c'est que on a une formation qui était
technique sur certains aspects assez
poussée même qui finalement n'a jamais
vraiment servi tant que ça alors que il
aurait bien mieux il aurait été beaucoup
plus pertinent d'avoir une formation
beaucoup plus globale général sert une
contextualisation de voilà le rôle d'une
banque le rôle d'un fonds
d'investissement des marchés financiers
ça marche comment sans rentrer dans le
détail de ces quoi le delta c'est quoi
le ghana et les conneries comme ça sur
les options on a rien à [ __ ] de sa
statue l'apprendra sur place ou tulle
apprendre à bien plus tard dans ton
processus universitaire quand tu vas te
spécialiser sur un truc dont on commence
vraiment par la base par un peu comment
ça marche
une espèce de mélange entre l'économie
et de la finance puis après petit à
petit on s'oriente vers les marchés
financiers parce que visiblement c'est
ce qui t'intéresse donc allons-y mais ça
mais jamais jamais moi j'ai mon premier
stage en banque d'investissement je sais
pas ce que c'était qu'un client serre
que tu arrives on te dit ouais tu veux
être assistant vendeur a ouais ça a
l'air génial donc tout le monde pouvait
être assistant vendeur ce que quand tu
viens d'école de commerce est pas facile
de trouver une place en salle des
marchés et la place attitrée c'est le
vendeur ce qu'on appelle le sails alors
c'est nous les mecs qui sortent d'écoles
de commerce ils peuvent être sails donc
tout le monde dit ouais assistant tu
peux commencer assistant vendeurs et
puis après tu pourras devenir vendeur
super assistant vendeurs de quoi déjà ça
c'est pas très clair mais surtout vendre
à qui aucune idée moi j'étais persuadé
que les clients des banques c'était des
gens tu vois des gens riches mais pas du
tout c'est les fonds d'investissement je
n'avais aucune idée de ça et pourtant
c'était une notion de base
enfin bref tout ça c'était complètement
opaque obscures donc je pense que je de
jeu voyage donnerait ce genre
d'information est peut-être que j'en
orienterait aussi sur la programmation
parce que c'est la programmation ça a
été une révélation j'ai appris tout seul
et j'ai trouvé ça génial jeu
jamais une cour de ça donc peut-être que
j'aurai un peu aussi poussé aussi le
pouce raymond mois dû passer par là pour
voir s'ils préfèrent passer à la finance
voilà pourquoi est ce que tu penses les
écoles de commerce et enseignes ou pas
cette vision un peu plus globale et la
programmation
je pense qu'ils sont un peu enfermé dans
l'eure dans leur idée que pour être pour
être pour être efficace il faut proposer
un outil adapté sa la formation enfin
les gens ce sont des outils que
l'entreprise utilise émettent une vie
cela un écrou là un boulon là une
planche line et donc toi toi tu es tu
arrivé il faut que tu sois une planche
où il faut que tu sois une vi où il faut
que tu sois un écrou tu as et donc
l'école de commerce elle essaye de te
formaté comme ça pour que tu sois pouf
prêt à usage sauf que
sauf que je pense qu'il ya une autre
dimension à la formation c'est
simplement orienter les gens dans leurs
choix serre que les gens comprennent ce
qu'ils choisissent et donc il ya toute
cette partie contextualisations qui est
je crois que les écoles de commerce se
pose pas cette question là voilà elle
part du principe que les gens veulent un
taf
donc tu veux un taf je vais te
transformer en vis et tu vas voir
l'entreprise va le prendre et zouk
elle va utiliser direct aura un boulot
et je pense qu'il faut aussi se poser la
question de les gens ils ont envie de
aussi de comprendre quel boulot il
aimerait faire et à ce moment là il faut
montrer toute la diversité des choses et
je suis pas certain qu'il prenne le
problème sous cet angle là ça se fait
d'autres réflexions que j'avais par
rapport à aulas est un autre domaine
mais pour le coup quand j'ai commencé ma
thèse en mathématiques appliquées
j'étais incroyablement ignorants sur
l'ensemble des mathématiques appliquées
enfin je connaissais assez bien le
domaine vers lequel je m'engageais mais
c'est très difficile d'avoir une vision
globale des choses et c'est pas vraiment
bien enseigner parce que c'est assez
compliqué et je pense que la plupart des
gens qui commencent une thèse
comprennent leurs petits domaines mais
c'est déjà difficile d'avoir une vision
globale de l'ensemble des mathématiques
appliquées même un truc un peu plus
restreint des mathématiques appliquées à
l'optimisation par exemple et c'est
encore plusieurs d'avoir une vision
globale au delà des maths qui inclut jeu
voilà la finance et l'économie à
biologie et tout ça c'est quelque chose
de très difficile
oui alors moi je ne dois pas enfin j'ai
quand je parle de ma vision du monde
c'est une vision de mécanique économique
et financière mais voilà je la jette des
notions bio de physique t'es pas
beaucoup de notions de maths voix très
et les docteurs a quand même réussi à
passer vraiment quelque chose de très
impressionnant de ces villes à avoir
cette vision en tout cas avoir une
vision assez globale de l'économie et de
la finance comment est ce que tu te les
construit comme ça imagine que c'est
arrivé
fascinant alors en fait ouais ouais
c'est pas c'est assez particulier parce
que je n'ai pas trouvé quelque part
serre que c'est un peu le tout la suit
pas mal je suis suffisamment sûre de moi
pour en parler
je sais que ça marche comme ça et je
pense vraiment pas me tromper parce que
ça colle avec beaucoup de descriptions
que je vais dire à droite à gauche mais
j'ai jamais trouvé quelqu'un qui me l'a
décrit de la manière donc moi je la
décris sur la chaîne c'est un peu moi
qu'il est sûrement d'autres gens qui
l'ont trouvée mais moi je n'ai pas lu
quelque part en tout cas ce truc là donc
on rentre aussi dans toute une notion de
légitimité de ces espèces est vraiment
pas facile d'être sûre et d'être à quel
point je suis sûre pour pouvoir en
parler de ces choses là et c est ce que
je suis légitime ou pas bon mais non ces
deux là c'est petit à petit quoi donc
première chose comment ça marche qu'est
ce que c'est que les marchés financiers
nous posent des questions qui sont des
questions genre d'où vient l'argent que
je vois pas c'est sûr mais sur mon écran
ou est-ce qu'il va cet argent là il
vient d'où est-ce qu'il va qu'est ce que
ça veut dire une capitalisation
boursière
quand on dit que apple vos chérubins pu
100 milliards aux gens ce nom mille
milliards c'est amazon qui le plus que
1000 milliards ou chez pull paraît donc
comme quand on his à amazon vomi
milliards par exemple ça veut dire quoi
est-ce qu'il ya cet argent ou pas ou est
ce que c'est juste un chiffre comme ça
va juste des considérations comme ça
très claire de pas mal de flux et de
stock et souvent monétaire donc quand il
ya une transaction qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se rendre compte que un billet de
10 euros peut changer demain trois fois
et du coup on va le compté trois fois
mais ça donc on va compter 30 euros mais
en fait il ya un seul billet qu'a changé
de mains trois fois donc commencé à
faire ces distinctions là quand on parle
aussi quand on parle de ça et après tu
arrives à essayer de construire une
espèce de mécanique de des marchés
financiers qui ressemble à une machine à
eau quoi ou une machine
moi j'imagine des tuyaux avec de l'eau
qui circule dedans et l'os et c'est ma
monnaie
et après j'ai des petits trous qui
tourne dans un sens qui fait défiler un
conteur et c'est donc ça en lisant des
descriptions des marchés financiers et
des livres sur la finance ont fini par
comprendre comment ça marche
donc ça c'était le premier travail de
comprendre la mécanique générale des
marchés financiers je suis loin d'être
un expert sur des tas de détails
techniques mais le fait d'avoir cette
compréhension générale fait que je pense
que je peux comprendre à peu près
n'importe quoi si tu ne donnes un truc
très techniques sur n'importe quoi le
fait d'avoir le contexte est d'avoir
compris la mécanique générale ça ça te
permet après ça tu ouvres la porte sur
un peu tout donc ça c'était le premier
truc à poser est gelée compris par mon
expérience professionnelle
par l'est les exemples de tous les jours
je m'occupais de faire de calculer les
résultats économiques des traders par
exemple ce qu'on appelle le pnl profilt
loss donc c'est moi qui calculait le
résultat du trader
j'ai passé un temps fou avec un avec un
ami un pote maintenant à essayer de
mettre en équation
ce ce résultat économique parce que je
travaillais sur un truc qui était qui
tombait pile entre deux cases donc
c'était pas clairement défini alors on a
dû travailler à le définir
et ça c'était passionnant en fait parce
qu on a fait plein d'erreurs et lui qui
avait enfin un background beaucoup plus
mathématique que moi et il voit il a
porté son truc et moi j'avais apporté un
autre et on la finit pas par des noues
et tout ça et c'était super ça ça m'a
beaucoup aidé à comprendre ces histoires
de stock de flux de mécanique etc
une fois que ça s'était posé là il y
avait la dimension économique
donc toute la machine économique donc on
sort la machine financière allait ans
elle est incluse dans la machine
économique
mais la machine financière eikon
spécifique la machine économique c'est
encore autre chose et donc là bas là ça
a été des livres essentiellement des
bouquins
et pour moi le plus le plus fort de ces
bouquins là c'est le bouquin un bouquin
de steve kean qui s'appelle d'e-banking
économique ce qui est vraiment pas
facile à lire mais pour moi c'est lui
qui m'a qui m'a permis d'avoir une idée
voilà une idée générale de
commentcamarche une idée globale de
comment ça marche
voilà donc ça se fait ça c'est petit à
petit oui et puis de façon générale donc
visiblement tu lis beaucoup de livres
mais est ce que ta question d autres
façons de t'informer abba you tube
beaucoup je suis beaucoup de chaînes de
vulgarisation de plus en plus en
français faudrait que j'arrive à me
remettre un peu avant je regardais
beaucoup de chaînes en anglais et
maintenant je sais pas pourquoi c'est
beaucoup plus de chaînes en français et
puis j'essaie de commencer un peu les
podcasts mais pour l'instant j'en
connais pas beaucoup
et puis quoi d'autre quoi d'autre donc
des livres et donc tu tu suis est-ce que
tu suis l'actualité
ouais sur twitter et sur un fort et six
étudiants
ouais pas mal tu tu lis régulièrement
des articles d'actualité
non je joli très peu les journaux je lis
très peu les journaux
voilà énoncée plus twitter twitter ça me
donne une idée un peu de ce qui se passe
tall et les petites polémiques les trucs
les machins je regardais interview je
regarde des interviews de deux
chercheurs un peu sur ses pages regarde
elle assure mediapart il propose ça je
trouve ça pas mal sinon je regarde les
truies de singer view ils font passer un
peu du monde dans tous les sens c'est
bien il ya des points de vue boya une
ligne quand même éditorial le signe
carew je dirais mais il ya des gens un
peu tous les horizons qui passe aussi et
donc c'est intéressant
voilà j'aime bien j'aime bien les
interviews longue de gens qui viennent a
peu parlé pendant quand je cherche une
vidéo de sueur sur facebook sur pas sur
facebook sur youtube par exemple je vais
systématiquement sélectionner les vidéos
les plus longues que les gens aient le
temps de s'exprimer que j'ai le temps de
comprendre un peu ce qui est ce qu'ils
veulent a raconté être besoin de temps
pour des vidéos aussi way qu'elle tape
l'impression parfois d'être parce que
j'imagine que du coup tu es quand même
moins au courant de l'actualité que
plupart des gens t'as pas l'impression
de manquer quelque chose par rapport aux
soldes alors moi ce qui me manque c'est
l'interaction avec les autres cercles je
suis à londres à fut tout seul et je me
rends bien compte que j'ai un problème
avec ça je manque d'interaction
j'aimerais bien faire rebondir mais idée
enfin échanger des idées avec d'autres
et j'ai du mal à le faire il faut que je
trouve une solution pour pour sortir un
peu de ça donc justement twitter
regarder youtube tout ça ça me permet
d'être au courant un peu des débats
je ne pense pas que je sois si mal
informés que ça mais par contre ce qui
manque c'est de discuter avec des gens
qui sont informés de manière différente
que moi et ça ce que je peux pas tout
voir tout regardé j'ai mon biais de
sélection et c'est bien de tomber sur
des gens qui vont avoir un biais de
sélection différents et comme ça tu ça
te permet un peu de rafraîchir les idées
donc au visionnement tâte un petit peu
peur de ce biais de sélection
qu'est ce que tu as des comptes eut gers
je ne sais pas comment je n'ai pas j'ai
pas mis en place de process pour le
gérer je pense que j'ai c'est d'être
attentif à la critique
voilà donc genre les commentaires sous
les vidéos ou les trucs comme ça s'est
passé vraiment pas évident je n'ai pas
de je ne sais pas dire ce qu'il faudrait
faire
mais disons que je quand j'ai quand j'ai
un commentaire négatif constructif ça va
pas juste un mec qui dit t'es con bon ok
merci et merci développer juhasz alors
pourquoi je suis con et quand j'ai un
mec qui m'explique pourquoi je suis con
et ben souvent je je je commence par le
croire ça ma première ma première
réaction c'est de me dire il a raison
et après d'essayer de voir comment je
pourrais mon échappée de ce truc là et
là je me vois j'arrive à voir si je mens
échappe facilement et pour des raisons
qui sont qui me semble correct
paju des raisons genre ouais des faux
argument quoi et si j'arrive pas à mon
échappée où je me dis bah ouais et bien
là ça veut dire qu'il faut lire
différemment il faut faire un correctif
il faut voilà et quand quand tu choisis
d'ailleurs les livres que tu ailleurs et
justement ce qu'il n'y a pas de
réflexion autour de ça
non pas vraiment les livres que je vais
lire j'ai choisi juste par rapport à
l'intérêt ouais je juste par rapport à
l'intérêt que j'en ai mais ça fait
partie des choses qui il faut que je
qu'il faut que j'apprenne à faire mieux
cers ne pas le dire que des gens qui
pensent comme moi ou qui vont aller un
peu dans mon sens et ça pour l'instant
j'ai encore beaucoup de mal à le faire
j'ai lu des livres sur certains penseurs
économiques par exemple qui sont des
livres écrits par des gens sur les
pensées de ses économies matures et il
faut que j'arrive à remonter au matériel
original ça pour l'instant c'est un truc
que j'ai pas encore bien fait et en même
temps et en même temps je trouve que
dans les livres que je lis j'arrive à
déceler la partie si tu veux moi ce qui
m'intéresse par exemple quand je vais
lire sur la pensée de soi keynes ou
hayek ou peu importe j'ai jamais lu
j'ai lu quelques textes de hayek et de
keynes mais j'ai pas lu j'ai pas j'ai
pas lu l'oeuvre principale de kane
dessous de hayek
mais quand je vais lire des mecs qui
décrivent comment y pense on voit bien
c'est à deux parties à la partie une ces
voix là comment y penser partie 2 voilà
pourquoi il a tort et je pense que
j'arrive à faire suffisamment la
distinction entre ça pour prendre juste
qui m'intéressent faire moi je veux
comprendre juste comment il pense
après la critique bon voilà mais il
n'empêche que pour que ce soit plus
précis il faudrait quand même remonter
aux sources
tu penses que ta prendrait beaucoup en
lisant hayek et qu'ils directement ben
oui je pense que je pourrais apprendre
après c'est ça aussi c'est le fait de se
perdre dans le parce que tu as un
certain temps tu vois donc par exemple
kane silva mentionné des trucs
techniques qui vont pas m'intéresser ce
qui m'intéresse c'est plutôt sa pensée
un peu politique ou philosophique
derrière parce que techniquement
j'ai compris le principe tu vois pareil
pour hayek
je sais ils font des erreurs qui sont
classiques dans les méthodes de
fonctionnement de l'économie la création
de la monnaie et tout ça c'est des
machins en maintenant ses classiques
tutu retombe toujours sur les mêmes les
mêmes trucs
par contre essayez de dents d'extraire
la pensée un peu politique ça ça
m'intéresse en ce moment j'ai un peu
peur que je dans un bouquin de 400 pages
je vais pas je vais me perdre dans les
détails tu vois je vais pas réussir un
don qui est aussi un gain de temps de
pouvoir lire un philosophe qui a
travaillé sur hayek et qui dit voilà il
ya qui pensent comme ça c'est vrai que
c'est cool
il ya déjà c'est déjà extrait ce que tu
voulais quoi donc pas mon expérience
c'est à dire des vieux textes c'est
souvent assez mitigé qu'il ya des îles
et passages parfois qu'ils sont vraiment
intéressants j'ai passage de la place
que j'ai trouvé vraiment ont très bien
expliquées voire mieux expliquer que les
gens qui expliquait la place turing
aussi les trucs qui sont vraiment
fenomeno par contre va et condorcet ou
cauchy c'était c'était laborieux voire
ses fils et des phrases qui en termine
pas passer un style de l'époque c'est
aujourd'hui on vend à prix bas a compris
plus de choses du coup on sait ce qui
est important on retire un peu ce qui
est peu important d'un langage plus
concis this beaucoup plus des équations
qui permet en fait de communiquer
beaucoup d'informations très peu de
symboles de façon très précise ce qui
est beaucoup plus agréable que des des
longs paragraphes pour expliquer à une
équation tout il ya des plus et des
moins
ça dépend des auteurs et puis faut être
patient parce que même turing turenne ya
plein d'idées vraiment génial mais aussi
vous placer dans le contexte de l'époque
à l'époque il faut y avait pas de
machine partout du coup turing doit
expliquer ce qu'est une machine et leur
ai expliqué et ça ça me en ce moment je
dis je m'intéresse pas mal aux idées
politiques des auteurs et en lisant des
choses sur adam smith notamment sa
madame smith adam ferguson et tout ça va
limite donner envie de reprendre les
textes de ces gars là pourtant ces 18e
c'est xviiie siècle un donc c'est ça ça
paraît très lointain mais il ya une
vraie différence en tout cas de ce que
je dis pour le moment entre ce qu'on
entend dire de des lumières écossaise un
peu et ce qui avait l'air d'être
effectivement leur leur pensée puissante
m smith j'avais si j'ai un petit peu
plus la domination et c'est quand même
laborieuse et puis à beaucoup de
chiffres beaucoup de données donc c'est
assez bien il a bien fait son boulot
n'est pas toujours très rigolo à lire et
dire d'accord alors donc finalement non
alors il ya sans doute des choses que
j'ai loupé j'ai peut-être pas passe pas
ma passion première vrai dire mais je
pense qu'il ya des trucs intéressants
clairement mais c'est pas toujours une
bonne idée de revenir mais je pense
qu'il ya des choses à apprendre aussi ça
va c'est sûr après c'est aussi le
problème c'est le sait le nombre c'est
la quantité ça en plus moi je suis pas
un cerveau super brillant donc quand je
lis un bouquin compliqué je mets du
temps quoi à bien comprendre à bien le
que ce soit clair dans mon esprit tout
ça je n'ai pas du tout l'impression
d'être capable d'ingurgiter un truc en
trois jours la chute
donc si je passe deux semaines sur un
truc c'est chiant si après je me dis bon
bah c'était nul n'est pas prêt grand
chose c'est pas évident je sais pas s'il
ya des gens qui seraient capables
peut-être qu'à des sites il note un
petit peu la lisibilité des anciens
auteurs
parce que ça varie pas mal d'un auteur à
l'autre je pense qu'il ya la lisibilité
mais il ya aussi l'information tu va en
retirer quoi parce que par exemple lire
les chiffres d' adam smith
moi ça va pas ça pas particulièrement
m'intéressait ce qui est ce que je veux
c'est essayer de comprendre sa pensée
pourquoi ils raisonnent de la manière
d'en tirer zone comment ils comment ils
envisagent parce que derrière l'économie
le marché le libéralisme il ya une
véritable idéologie en fait et les cc
intéressant de comprendre pourquoi on va
penser par exemple que la compétition
pourquoi on va penser si souvent ça
présuppose que on en imagine que l'homme
se comportent de telle manière ou à
telle à telle que qualités naturelles
toi et moi c'est ça que j'aimerais
comprendre c'est comment ils envisagent
les hommes comment il en villa de la
société comment il envisage l'avenir est
ce que ce qu'il pense qu'il ya un dieu
qui il gère tout où est ce qu'ils
pensent qu'au contraire non du a juste
créé les règles et après les allemands
font ce qu'ils veulent ou tu vois ce
genre de ce genre de choses et le truc
ce serait tomber sur un ouvrage où il va
me parler de ces chiffres et c'est pas
ça qui m'intéresse je cherche un truc
par rapport à ses auteurs ce qu'elle ait
des choses qui sont vraiment que tu as
découverte qui était pas du tout ce à
quoi tu t'attendais alors pour l'instant
en fait je dirais que mon mon analyse
donc j'arrête pas de changer d'avis sur
plein de choses et je n'arrête pas
d'apprendre tout le temps plein de
nouvelles choses c'est aussi un des gros
problèmes de la vulgarisation et de
serre que je fais des vidéos et après je
continue de lire et je me dis [ __ ]
j'aurais peut-être qu'il va faire comme
ça en fait cette vidéo j'aurais parce
que là en fait je dis ça mais j'oublie
de à c'est sans fin en fait tu t'arrêtes
pas d'accumuler des nouvelles choses et
c'est jamais fini
donc c'est en constante mutation
évolution désirait que pendant une
grande partie du temps je me suis
intéressé à la technique
donc voilà les histoires de tuyauterie
ou est-ce que ça passe là il ya une
vanne layana pas là il ya une règle n'y
a pas de règles etc et maintenant je
m'intéresse un peu plus à la
aux idées si tu veux aux bases qui
servent de qui servent de socle à la
théorie derrière on va pouvoir mettre
des équations et des choses mais à la
base il nous faut des axiomes et donc
ces choses là qui m'intéressent en ce
moment et là et là je sais plus ce que
c'était que ta question
ce cas les trucs surprenant est longue
voilà donc donc je suis surpris d'une
autre manière a maintenant avant j'étais
surpris de découvrir que certaines
théories ne vois pas les choses
correctement ça typiquement l'exemple
qui revient à chaque fois c'est la
création monétaire
tu vas lire une théorie et ils vont dire
l'âme et la monnaie crée de telle
manière et tu dis mais c'est pas vrai ça
enfin je veux dire on a la preuve que
c'est pas comme ça et bah ouais mais non
nous on continue comme ça
ok elle a ça ça me choquerait
complètement je les aimais c'est pas
possible comment comment on peut pas
changer la théorie si on est au courant
que donc ça c'était ça c'était 7,7
toutes ces premières phases de
recherches et maintenant je suis plus
c'est pas que ça me choque plus que ça
parce qu'il faut bien partir de quelque
part mais c'est enfin comprendre ce que
les gens en tête sur sur ce qu'est
l'humanité sur ce que sont les hommes
sur ce que c'est beaucoup plus à une
récession plus philosophique quoi on se
rend compte que ben il ya les théories
économiques y aller match mais au final
l'économie ça reste c'est très politique
il ya une vraiment une idée de ce que
devrait être de ceux de ce qu'est ou de
ce que devrait être la société qui est
derrière un peu chaque penseurs et le
fait de découvrir ça je trouve sa source
à assez incroyable c'est pas que
celui-ci
tout ça me choque et du coup ils
truquent surprenant chez ces auteurs
ouais des trucs surprenant vraiment par
exemple là je lisais que
ferguson qui est donc une mec qui
faisait partie des lumières à écossaise
j'ai même pas regarder ces dates
mais je pense que c'est un contemporain
dames et smith ferguson qui écrivait il
ya une espèce de dévolution historique
naturel de l'homme qui parle donc tu
sais l'homme au début il vit en tribu
fin chasseur cueilleur et puis ensuite
c'est des hordes donc c'est un peu plus
organisés mais c'est aussi plus violents
et puis ensuite il ya la société
marchande et la société marchande qui
perçoit comme un niveau encore au dessus
en terme de violence c'est pas le même
genre de violences est moins physique
mais c'est quand même une forme de
violence et qui oublient va dire mais en
fait à la fois il ya une processus
naturel de l'évolution humaine vers
toujours plus de deux biens matériels et
de connaissances etc etc et la société
devient de plus en plus complexes saïdi
que le moteur de sa c'est la division du
travail donc là on retrouve un peu adam
smith la division du travail qui permet
ça et il dit il ya deux moteurs
principaux chez l'homme motor numéro un
c'est préservation de son intérêt donc
de sa santé physique
il faut manger faut dormir etc mais il
ya aussi une volonté d'être un peu comme
rousseau tu vois d'être un homme bon
d'être d'être moral d'aider son prochain
de toutes ces petites toute cette ce
lien social en fait qui se crée entre
les gens on est amis on est frères on
est amoureux etc et il dit donc il ya
deux choses il ya l'intérêt préserver sa
personne et en même temps cette histoire
de lien social et les deux sont font
partie de la nature humaine et il dit le
problème c'est que le la
complexification de la société a
tendance à faire à faire en sorte que
l'intérêt personnel et les intérêts
personnels se met à dominer se met à
dominer et toutes là toute la notion
sociale tout le
toute la partie lien social se met à ce
contrat comme ça as restreint je
n'arrive pas à l'expliquer correctement
mais bref et mais il dit en fait c'est
naturel c'est c'est comme ça l'homme
évolue comme ça naturellement et du coup
il dit pas que on va arriver à une
société une société utopique où tout le
monde sera heureux dans le futur et que
l'humanité ce nom il dit c'est comme ça
en fait c'est naturel voilà ce qui se
passe et effectivement on constate qu'il
ya de moins en moins de bien social et
ça pourrait très bien mener la société à
sa perte
mais il n'empêche que le libéralisme
parce que donc lui l'analyse le
libéralisme et guibal le libéralisme
c'est juste la seule voie c'est la voie
naturelle de l'évolution humaine et très
fataliste quoi dans sa description
en tout cas de ce que j'ai compris et
mai mais en étant quand même mais en
analysant quand même très bien que il ya
plein de choses qui vont pas que oui on
laisse les enfants crevé dans la rue que
il ya des gens qu'on pas de travail qui
arrive pas à survivre cassé c'est
terrible à une violence terrible mais
voilà c'est comme ça c'est et donc c'est
intéressant ce qu'on attend on a
tendance parfois à diaboliser un peu
c'est autant dire ouais m comment est ce
qu il pouvait penser ça et ce qu'ils
voyaient pas s'il voyait tu vois et ça
rentre clairement dans leur raisonnement
donc ça je trouve ça vraiment très
intéressant qui sont capables de voir ça
mais il ya le côté est fataliste et donc
il ya l'idée d'envisager le rôle de
l'état en disant à la limite les tailles
peut peut-être ici et d'amoindrir un peu
ce truc là peut-être essayé d'aider un
peu
mais bon mais ça servirait à rien
d'aller à l'encontre du libéralisme
parce que tu as on sait il ya juste pas
d'autre voie c'est l'enchaînement
naturel des choses
certes raison si on passe à autre chose
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as encore des
relations avec le monde de la finance un
petit peu way
j'ai encore des amis qui travaillent en
finance et puis mes anciens collègues
même si je les vois quand même pas très
souvent ça m'arrive d'aller d'aller
prendre une bière avec eux du coup tu
parle un peu de toutes ces réflexions
non non c'est pas un truc que jose
abordés c'est pas évident j'ai remplacé
c'est cadeau déjà il ya différents
niveaux
il ya il ya mes collègues les anciens
collègues qui sont des jeux les jeux les
catégories spa quand même dans le dans
les amis tu vois c'est un petit peu en
dessous et il ya certaines personnes que
je considère comme des amis et même là
il ya encore une hiérarchie qui fait
qu'il y en a certains qui sont très très
proches je peux je peux me je sens que
c'est bon c'est je peux leur parler un
peu de tout de ce que j'en pense etc
et il y en a d'autres où je n'ose pas
aborder trop le sujet parce que voilà
parce que ça ça pourrait peut-être les
froisser ou ça pourrait peut-être les
voilà c'est pas évident je trouve donc
voila et j'ai l'impression que il ya
aussi des gens où je me dis c'est
peut-être pas ça qui les intéresse pas
envie de parler de ça donc c'est passé
pas toujours évident c'est pas toujours
évident mais du coup si jma pour passer
d'être altruiste envers l'humanité ce
que tu pense qu'il y assez important de
tangage et ce afin de faire en sorte que
ces personnes réfléchissent pas au
fonctionnement global de la finance et
aux conséquences que cela peut avoir
bah ouais ouais je pense que c'est
clairement important après le tout la
technique c'est d'être ne pas être
accusateurs quoi explicateur mais pas
accusateurs donc il faut pas que les
gens quand on commence à dire la finance
c'est pour moi il ya un des problèmes de
la finance notamment c'est que c'est
trop rémunéré quoi c'est s'est payé
beaucoup trop cher ça il va y avoir un
rôle de la finance et de lac et y est
indéniable cia il n'ya pas à tortiller
dans le monde tel qu'il est construit
aujourd'hui la finance est très
importante sans elle il ya plein de
choses qui marchent qui marcherait
beaucoup moins bien mais il n'empêche
que le problème c'est le rôle et le
pouvoir qu'on lui donne mais moi c'est
ça que je trouve dommage et que je pense
qu'il faut questionner donc c'est pas
évident d'arriver à dire aux gens mais
tu crois pas qu'en fait tu devrais
gagner trois fois moins sans les faire
se braquer tu vois pas ce que moi c'est
plus ça que je que je que j'aurais
tendance à dénoncer
il ya certaines choses qui devraient
être un peu qui devrait être mieux
régulée et c'est ça je suis d'accord je
pense surtout qu'il ya une question de
salaire c'est un problème de clefs de
répartition entre ceux qui gagnent
beaucoup ceux qui viennent pas beaucoup
et pourquoi il y en a qui gagnent
beaucoup pourquoi y en a qui viennent
pas beaucoup je crois que notamment en
finance ça devrait gagner beaucoup moins
que ça et voilà comment tu arrives à
amener la chose de manière constructive
sachant que encore une fois c'est un peu
ce qu'on disait les gens ben voilà ils
ont lors ils ont leur famille ils ont
lors ils ont leurs habitudes ils ont
leur fin et où ils vont ils vont me dire
non mais attends c'est pas juste moi moi
je suis arrivé dans un jeu j'ai regardé
les règles j'ai observé les règles
et puis je me suis dit bon bah je vais
aller là et là d'un coup en cours de
route tu me change les règles et
coutumes tu me j'avais fait tout un plan
de vie maintenant j'ai une famille j'ai
des enfants j'ai des projets j'ai des
rêves gd tout et tout est lancée là et
toi tu me change mes règles tu veux me
divisé par trois mots
mais ça va pas et je comprends tout à
fait ses respects facile c'est très très
difficile donc je sais pas si tu as déjà
entendu parler de ça peut-être que tu as
commencé à entendre parler ce que
j'étais coincé le podcast mais sur haiti
now now world qui parle beaucoup des
façons de voir des carrières altruiste
et efficace qui font un maximum de biens
est en tout cas au début ça change
peut-être en ce moment mes autres cas au
début j'ai une des carrière qui
suggérait c'est de faire des carrières
qui font beaucoup d'argent donc
typiquement dans le monde de la finance
et de donner peut-être 10% des revenus
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
semble possible souhaitable décidé
d'encourager ce genre de mouvements
altruiste dans le monde de la finance
est ce que c'est faisable à ce que à oui
c'est sûrement assez sûrement faisable
c'est sûrement faisable picot commencé
parce qu'on a donné des trucs parce que
si on passe tout de suite à 10% ça peut
faire ça peut faire un peu bizarre se
faire un petit choc est donc un des
trucs qui conseille souvent saisis
doivent commencer à donner peut-être 1%
c'est pas grand chose et puis c'est une
montée et puis on peut avoir un peu
comme lorsque on fait du sport si on
coupe les gens qui courent et ce
chronomètre il regarde le score qu'ils
font il essaie de progresser année après
année et pourrait avoir un petit peu un
phénomène comme ça si de valoriser le
fait de donner une grosse portion de de
ses revenus non ces mouvements la tribu
efficace ouais alors moi je ne suis pas
je trouve que c'est une chauffe et c'est
une bonne idée et je pense qu'en plus il
ya des probablement beaucoup de
financiers qui serait qu'ils seraient
d'accord pour faire ce genre de choses
il ya toujours la question du à quoi va
être à quoi va être utilisé mon argent
est ce que je me fais pas avoir parce
que finalement je donne pas 10% pour qui
un mec qui s'achète une villa à malibu
et c'est un ska mais voilà donc moi
c'est comme ça que je le ressens en tout
cas quand je signe ou pas pour gagner x
euros tous les mois pour une association
c'est avec jamais trop à savoir donc il
ya cet aspect là après donc il faut
qu'ils aient cette transparence machin
mais je pense que c'est tout à fait
possible
à
le jeu aussi c'est moi moi je remets ça
beaucoup sur les idées politiques c'est
à dire que ici on est dans là on est
dans le dans la version pour avoir pour
pouvoir changer la société allait de
vers les jobs qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent et redistribuer ensuite une
partie de ce que vous gagnez une autre
façon d'analyser le truc c c c c'est pas
normal qu'ils aient des gens qui gagnent
trop et il va falloir changer la société
pour que les gens qui gagnent 3 ar est
de gagner trop et que tu vois genre il
n'y a pas besoin d'eux on pourrait on
pourrait essayer de changer le système
politique pour que directement ceux qui
gagnent pas beaucoup gagnent plus
est ce qu'il ya une trop gagnent moins
et pas essayer de dire bon le système
est tel qu'il est on pourra pas le
changer donc on va essayer de motiver
ceux qui gagnent trop à donner a
contribué un machin qu'on va ainsi de
pouvoir redistribuer
donc je pense qu'il ya les deux il faut
pas perdre de vue les deux les deux
choses à la fois cette partie là qui est
probablement très efficace maintenant
parce que voilà si tu veux changer les
choses at on niveau bas tu vas pas
changer le système politique
enfin c'est peut-être pas y arriver tout
seul donc pourquoi pas faire des dons
mais gardez en tête que à mon sens il ya
aussi l'option 2
ah ouais changer les clés de répartition
qui font que à terme il y aura plus
besoin d'aller donner comme ça dix pour
cent de ses revenus parce que ce qu'il
ya une peu ils gagneront suffisamment
maintenant pour pour survivre donc et ça
on se rapproche un peu des idées
politiques
est ce que tu sais il ya les
libertariens américains ils vont avoir
tendance à dire ça et voir avant c'est à
dire il faut un minimum d'état il faut
un minimum d'état et au final la liberté
individuelle de gagner de l'argent
eh ben on peut pas toucher à ça donc on
peut pas prélever d'un pont peut pas par
contre les individus doivent êtres
moraux et ensuite se rendent compte que
c'est bien de donner une partie de ce
qu'on a gagné pour aller aider les
pauvres etc
donc tu vois on avec cette méthode on va
un peu dans le sens d'une idéologie
politique déjà non je crois que c'est
bien de faire ça mais de se rendre
compte que on va dans le sens d'une
idéologie politique et donc de se poser
la question aussi de cette idéologie est
ce que c'est la bonne est ce qu'on est
d'accord et et après chacun chacun est
libre de d66 ou quoi en effet c'est
intéressant tout ça la question qu'on me
pose c'est quelle serait la meilleure
façon de motiver les gens de la finance
a donné 10 % de leurs yeux alors c'est
une bonne question a donné 10 % de leurs
revenus
je pense que les gens de la finance ils
vont avoir un premier une première
réflexion c'est déjà les attaquer sur le
côté de l'altruisme efficace je pense
que c'est une bonne méthode
parce que les financiers vont se dire
rationnelle voilà donc c'est d'ailleurs
c'est souvent l'argument qui ressort
avec les gens qui ont de petits sont
milliardaires qui vont dire moi j'ai
fait une
j'ai créé une charité j'ai créé une
association et cette association est
beaucoup plus efficace que si j'avais
payé un impôt par exemple donc en fait
là tu va taper vert tu va taper là
dedans tu dis va regarder là c'est une
charité elle et private elle est privée
on essaye de faire quand même du profit
avec donc ça veut dire que quelque part
il ya un côté ça va marcher c'est
efficient efficace donc ça tue le tue
leur parle du coup c'est un peu
difficile parce que je pense que eux ils
vont avoir plus tôt la notion du si je
donne je récupère quoi toi une histoire
de rendement derrière qui revient il va
y avoir une histoire de rendement donc
ça c'est pas évident triste ouais c'est
pas c'est pas évident de jouer sur les
sur les deux tableaux si tu donnes et
10%
est ce que tu penses que je suis pas si
on n'arrive peut faire un truc pour que
ça devienne koulou qui se soit un peu le
genre tu peux un peux te la péter auprès
des autres traders en disant à 21 ans
j'ai donné 10 % moi je donnais 20 % à
ouais ça pourrait il pourrait y avoir
une notion de tu sais d'eux il faudra
une espèce de hiérarchisation ou deux je
pense qu'il ya quelque part il ya une
espèce de 2 c'est arthur donne 10 % mais
tu veux savoir quel impact a eu quoi
donc
à la limite le fait d'avoir un retour
sur investissement ça permet de se dire
voilà ça a été efficace
j'ai donné 18 reçu j'ai récupéré 11
gagner plus
c'était efficace donc là il faut être
capable de dire avant que je donne 10 le
bonheur des autres il était à 22 et
après que j'ai donné il est passé avant
de capture à j'ai eu un impact une
espèce d'indicés une espèce de chose qui
mesure l'impact de ta donation ça je
pense que ce serait important et c'est
intéressant parce que du coup dans le
mouvement estrien efficace il ya des
méta charité dès qu'ils sont capables
qui tout frais dont le rôle est de noter
les autres charité du coup de feu serait
capable du son de fournir sur deux
chiffres dès 13h10 en break telle somme
vous sauver tel nombre de vie par
exemple quelque chose comme ça et puis
ou tel nombre de de qualité de vie en
bonne santé ou plus comme ça et puis
après il ya un autre truc qui est assez
intéressant dans des podcasts dans ma
robe line parée de sa où il parlait de
aujourd'hui je pense que
il ya des domaines qui sont il pense et
je pense aussi qu'il ya des domaines de
la trisomie fiscales qui sont bien
balisé commencer vous si vous donne et l
argent pour telle fondation ça va sauver
at-elle nombre de vies on est capable de
savoir quasiment où nombre de vies
presse
et puis à d'autres domaines notamment
qui sont plus y ait de la recherche sur
la liste des essentiels par exemple ou
europe
robert tribune parle de venture
capitalists de l'altruisme des gens qui
sont capables de vaincre les voitures
cap this means puis ceux qui
investissent mais aussi des
entrepreneurs de de la très efficace qui
sont capables de porter des projets très
risqués qui ont de bonnes chances de
faire énormément de bien mais qui bon
potentiellement vont rien découvrir du
tout du coup ça pourrait être
intéressant
j'ai pas s'y connaît par exemple la
l'organisation qui s'appelle open et
haye qui a été monté par des étais monté
par des milliardaires faut notamment il
aux mosquées et d'autres et donc ça
ressemble vraiment à un truc de c'est
vraiment une start up de crise efficace
d'une certaine manière ou leurs idées
ces deux voiliers voulait mettre des
milliards sur je sais pas s'ils ont mis
des milliards mais au moins des millions
je crois qu'au final ça fait des mineurs
sur des solutions techniques pour rendre
les ja bénéfique
ok et openni bonbons ils ont démis des
milliards sont recrutés lumière donc
forcément c'est pas ça c'est pas
forcément très surpris mais du coup au
général s'est fait un nom et aujourd'hui
c'est reconnu comme l'une des meilleurs
endroits de recherche sur la sécurité
des typiques mans donc peut-être que
s'il ya d'autres projets similaires qui
se lance
voilà c'est peut-être que ça peut
attirer les fonds d des financiers je
pense que j'imaginais un truc un peu
plus satisfaisant à dire bon ben j'ai
investi dans tel truc parce que je pense
qu'ils vont faire des trucs vraiment
efficace terme d'altruisme ouais
sûrement après je je connais pas
suffisamment la notion d'altruisme
efficace pour avoir vraiment une
une idée là dessus donc j'ai du mal à
jésus
j'ai du mal à me représenter ce que ça
pourrait à quoi ça pourrait ressembler
par exemple tu vois ce serait et d'aider
un village à ne pas avoir accès à l'eau
ou à des fins c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
voies pour faire la très efficace
angot aujourd'hui les trucs de pauvreté
de qualité de l'eau de maladie fin c'est
surtout en fait les maladies qui pose
beaucoup de problèmes dans les pays en
voie développement et compris par an si
on veut s'intéresser à l'éducation dans
les pays en voie développement en fait
il se trouve souvent que c'est en
soignant les maladies en particulier le
malaria qu'on a qu'on améliore le plus
la qualité de vie des gens et en
particulier la capacité des enfants
allaient à l'école
donc il ya beaucoup de indirectement en
fait c'est souvent en soignant les
malades y con et ça s'est assez bien
compris d'une certaine manière
du coup on va y ait des associations qui
sont capables de dire ça vous fait elle
telle quantité de biens en quelque sorte
une typiquement l'une des mesures c'est
le nombre de qualité de vie qui
s'appelle les dialyses qui sont sauvées
tout ça c'est très intéressant et une
certaine r c'est un investissement
fiable d'une certaine manière mais 1000
euros dessus on sait à peu près ce qui
ce qui va en sortir
par contre il ya d'autres champs de
recherche qui sont souvent liées en fait
à la recherche parce que monty picon de
recherche c'est réduire notre
incertitudes sur des domaines qu'on
connaît très peu
du coup c'est très incertain on sait pas
trop ce que la recherche
sortir et là c'est un investissement
plus risqué avec des projets plus plus
plus incertain et donc c'est plus
difficile à quantifier mais je pense que
je peux jouer jean que les confidences
aime bien un peu le risque aussi et que
du coup s'il investit dans le prochain
open et à une certaine heure c'est assez
cool que tu veux mais ce qu'il ya c'est
que un tube ouais ouais non mais si
c'est cool j'ai du mal à j'ai du mal à
bien me représenter à bien me
représenter leur la manière de penser à
la fois j'ai pas suffisamment discuté
avec eux et ça commence à être un peu
loin en plus que j'ose pas aborder
certains sujets et aussi
moi je ne peux pas je fonctionne aussi
beaucoup en disant à leur place
tu vois là maintenant je suis tellement
éloigné d'eux parce que maintenant ça
fait plusieurs années que j'ai arrêté la
finance en plus souvent les personnes
auxquelles je pense fin mes collègues il
avait déjà une dizaine d'années d'avancé
sur moi en termes de carrière donc
maintenant où ils en sont en plus j'ai
pas d'enfant ni rien souvent c'est un
truc qui revient la famille là il ya une
volonté de vouloir de transmettre
quelque chose à ses enfants transmettent
souvent du patrimoine tout ça donc à
quel moment on se dit ok là il ya
suffisamment de patrimoine à transmettre
maintenant je peux m a donné où j'ai
aucune idée
c'est parce qu'il est de donner un
pourcentage est sans doute intéressante
pour ça parce qu'a priori cette voie
c'est plus facile donner un plus grand
pourcentage qu'on a plus d'argent bien
sûr mais parler en termes de pourcentage
plutôt qu en termes de quantité d'argent
c'est peut-être plus passer que c'est ce
que promet pas mal de 10 à nouveau en
particulier ouais d'accord
bon sinon pour en revenir à notre sujet
donc
donc t-elle expliqué que tape pas mal
d'incertitudes pm sur sur pas mal de
sujets c'est quand même compliqué la
finance et l'économie du coup est ce que
tu fait relire t script alors j'en ai
pas fait rire l'humour j'en ai pas fait
relire tant que ça dans les derniers
script là il y en a quelques-uns que
j'ai fait relire mes meiway sinon pape a
pas tant que ça pas tant que cela s'est
passé pas toujours évident de trouver
quelqu'un qui va qui soit su qu'ils
soient suffisamment compétent pour
relire le truc est aussi c'est un peu
que je t'ai je pense déjà dit il ya
cette partie il ya il ya un côté
susceptibilités qui rentrant qui rentre
en compte ce qu'est en ligne de compte
qui est indéniable c'est à dire je vais
faire rire mon truc on va me dire ah
mais ça c'est mal ça c'est ça va
m'énerver gérard du mal à supporter la
critique
je préfère à la limite je préfère le
maître comme ça et voir les critiques
dans les commentaires voilà tant pis
c'est homme je verrai les critiques dans
les commentaires et si j'ai fait
vraiment des erreurs énormes jean lèvres
à la vidéo où je posterai un commentaire
de mais avant que ce soit sorti comme ça
je sais pas c'est pas pareil je sais pas
expliquer je ne sais pas expliquer il ya
aussi un truc du voile à moi j'ai mon
mode de travail
tac tac tac là d'un coup hop il ya la
partie re lecture donc là faut que
j'attende je suis un matin et j'attends
qu'il ya le mec et relu voilà et ça ça
ça veut dire ça m'interrompt
complètement dans tout le monde en tout
le mond process est alors du coup je
commence à travailler sur autre chose et
là le gars me revient alors il faut que
j'abandonne ce nouvelle pour eux et je
déteste ça donc ça c'est un truc que je
déteste dans le monde de la recherche et
ses devoirs me replonger dans un article
que j'ai écrit il ya six mois que ce
comme ça avec des relectures qui sont du
côté des mauvaises expériences de
relecture non non pas particulièrement
en plus fin c'est simplement c'était
j'ai une espèce d'attentes de
je crois que c'est un truc très scolaire
en fait tu sais c'est tu donnes ta copie
à la maîtresse et après tout il va y
avoir les ratures en rouge là comme ça
sur ta feuille et ça ça ça je sais pas
pourquoi
pourtant c'est pas ce qui va se passer
les mecs vont pas me faire des traits
rouges surnom sur ma copine tu vois mais
je sais pas pourquoi c'est comme ça que
je le ressens alors c'est un mélange de
tout ça est pour l'instant j'ai jamais
eu trop de mauvaises expériences trop
importante sur une vidéo avec qui des
hommes majeurs mais je pense que le jour
où ça m'arrivera ça me forcera peut-être
bien faire relire les scripts du coup
quand tu as fait relire t script c'était
parti alors j'ai fait relire mes scripts
par un professeur à l'université de
montpellier qui est qui est docteur en
économie et en je crois qu'il est
docteur en mathématiques appliquées à la
finance
donc je l'avais fait relire le mans
scripps sur un sujet sur le pétrole
notamment et puis sur mon mon épisode
sur l'énergie je parlais d'un modèle un
modèle un peu technique
voilà utilisé en économie pour aborder
le problème de l'énergie et donc ça il a
passé un temps fou à me l'expliquer
chez fille j'ai mis du plomb avant de
comprendre et voilà donc lui ça mais
c'est parce que c'était trop
mathématiques sinon ouais un épisode sur
le pétrole et crois que c'est à peu près
tout en fait
et quand tu c'est quelqu'un que tu
connaissais ce professeur mon pays
ouais quelqu'un qui m'avait contacté
suite à une vidéo qu'elle avait trouvé
que c'était sympa et qui m'avait dit pas
si jamais tu as besoin n'hésite pas à
faire appel à moi était peut-être à
d'autres relations comme ça avec le
monde académique
pas tant que ça j'ai eu quelques j'ai
quelques personnes qui m'ont contacté
les gens du shift project donc c'est
jean-marc enfin oueds et des gens qui
s'intéressent à nos problématiques
d'énergie
voilà j'ai l'économie ce que je citais
avant la le stif qui a écrit des mains
qui economics elle était un peu ma
référence pour bien comprendre la
manière dont les économistes la manière
dont la théorie économique dominante
disons fonctionne lui c'est pareil mais
à les contacter suite à une de mes
vidéos martèle ce qui en plus il parle
anglais ne parle pas du tout français
donc ainsi un google translate dans les
sous titres ça a suffit donc quelqu'un
lui avait mentionné que je faisais des
vidéos quelqu'un que les francophones et
du coup il était revenu vers moi donc
lui je l'aï rencontré j'ai un moment
donné je lui avais posé quelques
questions et tout mais au final je me
suis rendu compte aussi que en discutant
avec ses deux personnes là globalement
comment dire en fait ils pouvaient
m'orienter vers des sujets qui avaient
déjà été traités
parce que moi je ne m'intéresse pas
d'être problématique trop trop précises
j'essaye de généraliser voilà donc donc
je suis jamais dans le truc où il faut
trouver exactement le mec experts dans
le domaine
donc ça va j'aurai suffisamment général
pour qu'on puisse lire différents
auteurs on arrive quand même à se former
une image a peu à peu près correcte de
ce qui se passe là où ils sont utiles
pour moi c'est ils vont dire justement
ils vont pré mâché le travail serge
images des images m'intéresse à ça et
ils vont bien banda il ya lui il ya lui
il ya lui il ya telle étude tel truc tel
machin
les quelques fois où j'ai fait j'ai fait
le test
en fait la moitié je les connaissais
déjà parce que j'avais commencé à
chercher j'étais tombé sur les gars bon
final voilà je pense que je dois avoir
une méthode de travail qui doit
fonctionner à peu près correctement
il ya aussi le fait que souvent les
données dont j'ai besoin pour faire les
analyses parce que c'est un peu des
analyses que je fais aussi c'est des
données qui sont disponibles sur des
bases de données et les chercheurs
utilisent ces données-là utilise ses
bases de données et je sais à peu près
les utiliser et donc du coup je retombe
toujours un peu sur mes pattes
très clair c'est un truc tu fait de tes
dès le début de ce que j'ai l'impression
que tu fais de plus en plus de l'analyse
de données comme ça je me trompe
ouais de plus en plus parce que en fait
au début dans ma manière de rechercher
je cherchais des articles tu vois je
vais chercher dans le monde le figaro
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas déjà parlé de
l'inflation ou de ci de ça et en fait il
dit oui l'inflation augmenté de 6% entre
temps étant telle date et elle date et
toi tu es là mais d'accord mais alors
donc entre 2003 et 2007 ça m'intéresse
pas moi je voudrais à la limite 1980
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et je veux voir la
courbe quoi je veux pas avoir vu des
trucs qui donc plus ça va plus tu dis il
faut que je remonte à la source de
l'information et après une fois que tu
as accès à toutes les cuvées très un peu
les bases de données ben c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant de de faire de
l'analyse du coup après il ya aussi des
idées de une fois que tu as compris les
mécanismes généraux c'est tout à fait
capable de raconter d'un c'est vraiment
pas évident expliqué et une fois que tu
as compris tu as compris les mécanismes
généraux tu étais capable de dire ben si
je veux parler de ça je vais avoir
besoin de cette donnée tu vois bien sûr
tout schéma ce truc là va interagir avec
ça donc il faut que je pense à ça il va
falloir que j'aille chercher ces données
live et donc t'as pas besoin de forcer
man 2 après ce que tu vas faire tu vas
faire ton analyse
moi ce que je fais je fais mon analyse
tactique j'ai trouvé mes données et
après je vais vous recherchez voir si
quelqu'un l'a déjà fait cette analyse là
et je regarderai ce qu'on match à peu
près ce que ça mais c'est rare que je
tombe sur quelqu'un qui a fait la même
analyse parce que souvent c'est d alix
trop générale et que quand tu vas dans
les papiers de recherche c'est des trucs
beaucoup plus précis il analyse un truc
en détail donc c'est un peu je m'assois
entre les deux entre des papiers de
recherche qui sont beaucoup plus précis
et des articles de presse qui sont eux
beaucoup trop généraux pour le pour le
coup c
moi je suis juste un peu entre les deux
et c'est pas facile de trouver des gens
qui ont déjà fait ça c est du coup dit
je connais d'autres personnes qui
essaient de faire un peu comme toi ou tu
te sens un peu serré le tracé domine bah
non je vois pas trop en fait
il ya des jeux je sais pas trop je sais
pas trop qui est ce qui fait ça est-ce
que c'est peut-être plus c'est un boulot
de de gens que vont écrire des livres
mais des livres avaient peut-être à
destination du grand public par rapport
à des livres qui sont vraiment orientée
recherche
je sais pas trop et d'un autre côté des
livres c'est quand même plus poussé que
ce que moi je fais dans une vidéo de 20
minutes tu vois donc non je ne serai pas
bien acquis à qui comparer ça sinon j'ai
envie d'aborder le sujet de la
légitimité
tu te sont gros ça je suivais la
légitimité je suis je me pose toujours
la question j'arrête pas de alors le le
sujet de la légitimité il est trés il
essaie un c'est un sujet passionnant
mais qui me qui me ronge
c'est donc en économie la l'économie est
elle une science est-ce qu'on peut
aborder l'économie sous le domaine soit
sous l'angle de la science et moi je
suis sur internet j'aime beaucoup suivre
tous les étés titien qui parle de la
méthode scientifique etc
donc je me renseigne beaucoup là dessus
et je trouve ça passionnant et est ce
que on peut prendre cette méthode
scientifique et l'appliquer à l'économie
en question et ça moi pour le moment
donc encore une fois mon peut-être mon
opinion révèle lui mais plus ça va plus
je m'éloigne de sa part que j'ai
commencé en disant l'économie est une
science et on peut le prendre on peut
prendre la méthode scientifique et
l'appliquer à l'économie et plus j'y
réfléchis plus je m'éloigne de cette de
ce postulat plus je me dis mais pas du
tout en fait l'économie ne peut
absolument pas être abordée sous l'angle
de la science donc pour l'instant c'est
cette direction que je prends mais je
sais qu'il ya des gens qui sont pas
d'accord et à chaque fois que je me
prends des petits pics par ces gens là
je me dis mince oui c'est vrai il ya un
consensus scientifique
enfin je veux dire il ya il ya deux
grands courants de pensée et on va dire
il ya ce qu'on appelle les orthodoxes et
les hétérodoxes alors les les orthodoxes
c'est un genre ça doit être 70% des
économistes et puis les hétérodoxes et
30% et donc du coup moi je je me
catégorise plus dans les hétérodoxes que
dans les orthodoxes juste parce que pour
moi la manière d'envisager l'économie
par les orthodoxes et beaucoup trop
étroite
je vois pas comment il arrive à fonder
légitimement qu'il faut analyser
l'économie par ce prisme là pour moi ça
devrait être plus large
donc je me catégories dont les
hétérodoxes mais d'un autre côté il ya
certains hétérodoxes qui eux aussi leur
prisme vachement étroit et avec lesquels
je suis pas d'accord pour moi il
faudrait tout envisagé tout le temps tu
vois et donc voilà
mais d'un autre côté ce prisme et 3d
orthodoxe c'est 70% des économistes il
semblerait est alors la question qui
revient souvent c'est je ne me pense pas
plus intelligent que ces 70 % dont je
suis même fort probablement beaucoup
moins intelligents que ces gens là
comment ça se fait que moi je suis pas
d'accord que j'arrive pas
voilà je devrais sûrement être d'accord
avec eux qu'est ce qui m'arrive
qu'est-ce qui se passe et voilà alors
que ça c'est un truc qui revient très
souvent et je n'arrive pas à répondre je
sais pas répondre à ça mais quand moi je
fais mes recherches et que je regarde
et ben non je n'y arrive pas rentrer
dans ce prisme là des orthodoxes je n'y
arrive pas
c'est basé sur des choses qui me
semblent être pas fondées défunt c'est
une analyse possible mais c'en est une
parmi d'autres qui est ok et il ya des
hypothèses en particulier qu'elles font
les économistes il doit bien sûr c'est
la question qu'on se pose c'est comment
est-ce qu'on donc ça repose sur le
libéralisme de bentham jeremy bentham
l'utilitarisme donc le lob est une
machine à calculer son intérêt
d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant de
voir que dans la théorie économique
on fait tous des choix ses choix on ne
s'en rend pas compte mais en fait on
calcule quand on va choisir glace à la
vanille ou glace au chocolat
on calcule dans notre tête le plaisir
qu'on va retirer de la glace à la
vanille et la glace au chocolat et on
choisit systématiquement su qu'ils nous
apportent le plus de plaisir
donc ça c'est la sas est un axiome de
base de la théorie économique
on se dit voilà comment se comporte
l'homme maintenant essayer de mettre en
équation
ce comportement là on va le généraliser
et on va en déduire les lois de
l'économie
donc le problème c'est que
mathématiquement pour être capable de
généraliser ça tu vas faire beaucoup de
dassault chase de commandites côté voilà
tu vas faire beaucoup d'hypothèses ben
que tu vas pas pouvoir vérifier en
fenêtres voire même qui sont pas
vérifiables par exemple une hypothèse
qui va être faite c'est de dire alors si
je prends une place à la vanille ça va
me rapporter par exemple 10 points
d'utilité et si j'en prends une deuxième
ça va me rapporter forcément la deuxième
glace va me rapporter moins de 10 points
10 points la première 9 points la
deuxième 7 points à la troisième 4
points et en plus de ça c'est des
croissances air que ça ça forme une
c'est quoi c'est une asymptote non c'est
une un moment donné tu vas tu
la croissance en fait la croissance de
la courbe est infinie donc non c'est pas
la croissance de la courbe est infinie
mais ça se réduit à chaque fois le taux
de croissance serait dû à chaque fois
d'accord donc ça c'est une hypothèse
mais ça ça jamais été testée est ce que
vraiment est-ce que c'est pas une glace
10.2 glace la deuxième rapporte 15
1 la troisième ne rapporte 20 points
donc c'est croissant au début et après
c'est décroissant en fait ça dépend de
ma faim non ici on part du principe que
systématiquement la première rapporte
plus de points que la deuxième - qui
rapporte plus de points que la troisième
etc etc
ça c'est un axiome qui permet d'avoir
une qui permet d'avoir une source d'
entité voilà exactement fonction
conclave merci donc ça permet d'avoir
une fonction concave et tu va raisonner
à partir de ça et donc le problème c'est
que sas ça n'a jamais été testé par
personne si c'est pas vrai il ya
beaucoup de trucs dans ta théorie qui
marchent plus un autre point qui est
donc par exemple un autre point
intéressant c'est de dire le choix il
est irrévocable cercle quand j'ai choisi
la glace à la vanille parce que j'ai
anticipé donc la glace à la vanille a
rapporté 10 points c'est le chocolat que
5 donc j'ai pris vanille il est hors de
question qui est quelqu'un qui arrive et
qui me disent du coup lui il a acheté
une glace au chocolat il dit est ce que
tu veux pas échanges et à glace au
chocolat contre mana glace à la vanille
contre ma glace au chocolat
non j'avais le choix de prendre une
glace au chocolat avant et je n'ai pas
prise j'ai pris la vanille parce que
c'est ça que j'aime
donc après je n'échangerais pas avec
quelqu'un bon ça ça a été testé ils ont
lâché des gens dans des supermarchés
avec un budget 100 euros et ils auront
dit vous croyez ce que vous voulez dans
le supermarché
donc le mec quand il sort avec son
caddie c'est son caddie à lui qui
maximise son utilité à lui donc il n'est
pas question de lui dire maintenant à
barr regarde je prends ta bouteille de
que 15 mai du pepsi à la place est ce
que ça te va où est ce que ça ne va pas
sachant que la bouteille de coca la
bouteille de pepsi était au même prix
donc le mec qui aurait pu prendre le
pepsi s'ils voulaient c'était dans le
magasin et là on lui propose de changer
il se trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui décident qu'ils acceptent le
changement ça ça va à l'encontre des
axiome de base
mieux on leur propose des caddies déjà
fait ses airs d'autres d'autres chariot
qui ont été faits avec 100 euros de
budget les gens ont fait le chariot qui
voulait et ensuite on leur montre
d'autres chariot fête va faire par
d'autres personnes avec un budget de 100
euros et on dit est ce que vous voulez
changer votre chariot contre un de
ceux-là et régulièrement il a qui
changent mais je me rappelle plus
exactement des proportions mais c'est
important quoi c'est limite la moitié
des gens disent ah ouais en fait le
chariot c'est il est mieux que le mien
ça contredit donc totalement le l'axiome
de départ et pourtant on reste là dessus
donc et la théorie repose
malgré tout là dessus parce que deux
c'est de ces comportements tu vas en
déduire la courbe de la demande qui va
vers le bas et et la courbe de l'offre
qui va vers le haut derrière et l
équilibre supposé de l'offre et de la
demande
ça vient de ça alors alors ici le
problème c'est de dire évidemment ce que
vont c'est de dire oui mais le but d'une
théorie économique
elle est passée pad ou de n'importe quel
modèle c'est pas de décrire parfaitement
la réalité c'est d'être le plus
prédictif possible c'est d'approcher le
réel le mieux qu'on peut et donc ce que
les économistes vont dire c'est bien
pour l'instant c'est ça qui approche le
mieux le réel est alors moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que ça le ça
suppose que le marché les forces de
l'offre et la demande vont de soi faire
que comment comment expliquer
aujourd'hui on a la liberté de consommer
il ya l'offre et la demande il ya le
prix qu'elle essais libres etc
on pourrait très bien avoir un système
de fonctionnement qui se base pas là
dessus on pourrait très bien avoir une
société où les prix sont kpc rien il ya
un prix maximum un prix minimum un
marché qui s'expriment entre les deux où
on pourra avoir une autorité centrale
qui fixe les prix où on pourrait avoir
pas de prix ou alors on pourra voir les
prix qui dépendent de la condition de
chacun pour il ya des milliers de choses
qui peuvent être imaginées mais le fait
de partir de cette théorie économique et
de dire que c'est de la science du coup
limite ses possibilités là on dit
maintenant
l'offre et la demande s'est on revient
sur l'idée de que je mentionnais tout à
l'heure de ferguson qu'il ya une
certaine naturalité dans le fait
d'organiser les choses de la manière
dont s'est organisée et moi je suis
dessus je vois pas en fait je suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que je vois pas
de preuve de ça c'est où est-ce qu'on a
prouvé ça nulle part en fait on a juste
on essaye de m on essaie de rendre
scientifique
l'analyse d'un mode d'organisation qu'on
a créés mais les racines de ce mode
d'organisation elles sont historiques
elles sont pas il se trouve que on est
tombé dans ce mode là
et ensuite on essaie de rationaliser la
manière dont ce truc là fonctionne
pourquoi pas mais le problème c'est que
avec les la vision des orthodoxes la
retourne le problème c'est hier que ces
put on choisit un peu le mode
d'organisation qu'on veut et après les
organisent les économistes ils doivent
essayer de comprendre comment ce mode
d'organisation peut être rationalisée le
mieux c'est plutôt les économistes
disent voilà le mode rationnel et du
coup la société est obligé de s'adapter
à ce mode là mais ça va pas pour moi moi
c'est d'abord les gens choisissent qui
est un peu ce qu'ils veulent faire et
après les économistes il analyse le truc
et 10 bon a priori si vous continuez
comme ça on va par là très bien ça ça ça
m'irait je remercie sais pas si c'est
clair dans ma manière de présenter les
choses c'est vraiment pas évident alors
et je pense qu'il ya pas mal de choses
dont apparaît enfin qui correspond à la
psychologie comportementale voir comment
les gens attendant avec des expériences
pour voir comment les choses se comporte
en vrai c'est quand même pas être
complètement négligé dans la théorie
économique
il me semble donc daniel kahneman a reçu
le prix nobel d'économie en 2001 quelque
chose 2011 12 quelque chose comme ça
pour des travaux reliés aux biais
cognitifs et la manière dont les gens
raisonnent ouais mais le problème c'est
comment est-ce que ça derrière ces pris
en compte dans la théorie serre que moi
ce qui me va pas c'est que ce qui ne va
pas c'est que je peux pas me voir comme
en tout cas alors en plus faut parler
économie mais faut parler macroéconomie
et c'est donc ce que tu peux expliquer
microéconomie et macroéconomie bas
typiquement typiquement le le prix nobel
dont tu parlais là ça va être serré
plutôt que là c'est ça dans la
microéconomie ça il s'intéresse au
comportement des gens comment les gens
réagissent et sert à ça ça va être de la
microéconomie la macroéconomie sais tu
veux chercher à avoir un modèle du monde
en fait 1 comment fonctionne l'économie
au niveau global et mon problème à moi
c'est justement de voir les passerelles
entre des découvertes comme on va faire
des découvertes comme a fait kahneman et
le comportement global de l'économie
et ça en fait ces passerelles elles sont
très maigres la macroéconomie ça reste
un truc ça reste une une modélisation
qui est quand même assez assez simple en
fait ça c'est complexe mais c'est assez
simple il ya plein de trucs qu'on
n'arrive pas à prendre en compte
et moi je pense qu'on devrait beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus comment prudent
vis-à-vis de ses modèles si je reformule
un peu ça
dis-moi si si si si je me trompe et donc
l'impression que la critique que tu fais
aux économistes orthodoxes c'est de dire
qu'ils sont un peu des docteurs john
si on prend notre fait toni dr john a
fait une vidéo collab sur ma chaîne là
dessus ou l'idée c'est que docteur john
cole beaucoup plus au modèle alors que
facto n'y serait plus capable de coller
aux données alors peut-être trop donné
mais peut-être qu'on doit être un peu
plus au milieu de ce spectre est ce que
c'est ça c'est encore plus c'est encore
plus compliqué que ça parce que
dr john est le seul à avoir un modèle
fat toni n'a pas de modèle il a juste
des idées il a pas il n'a pas trop de
donc c'est aussi un problème d
hétérodoxes qui vont pas forcément avoir
de modèle à opposer aux orthodoxes
après les offres de financement de l les
uns se plaignent de les uns vont dire à
vous n'avez pas de modèle lesotho n'y
arrive n'a pas de sous pour développer
des modèles et puis tu as on voulait pas
qu'on enseigne en cours contre sienne
dans les classes nos idées alors
forcément on n'a pas d'étudiants bon le
fait est que moi je suis assez éloigné
tout ça donc j'ai un peu du mal à me
rendre compte mais est-ce que ce que je
trouve c'est que yahia je connais un
autre modèle
voilà le modèle de keane donc c'est
toujours à steve king qui est repris par
pas mal des terreaux ducks qui a une
vision un peu plus le la version
orthodoxe c'est je commence par
l'individu je me pose la question de
savoir comment un individu résonne à
partir de là je met en équation
le comportement de cet individu ensuite
je me demande ce que c'est qu'une
entreprise comment une entreprise
résonne je met en équation
le comportement de l'entreprise je
confronte l'eau le comportement de
l'individu et le comportement de
l'entreprise offre demande
j'en déduis 1 un mode de fonctionnement
de l'économie
bon il est une approche mais il ya
d'autres approches et par exemple le
modèle de keynes et de dire je regarde
les chiffres et j'essaye de déduire des
choses de ce que je vois donc je vous
regarde le pays des jeux regard de
l'inflation je regarde l'entourage
regarde dans plein de pays essaie de
regarder s'il ya des trucs qui sont
corrélés et s'il ya des trucs qui voit
là et je vois pas pourquoi cette
approche là serait moins pertinente d'un
point de vue prédictif en plus simple si
c'est ça le but le but de modèles sai de
prédire je vois pas pourquoi cette
approche là serait moins prédictive
moins intéressante que la première et
donc du coup le problème c'est que la
deuxième méthode que je viens
d'expliquer ces catégoriser hétérodoxes
corps et donc tu vas pas pouvoir publier
partout et tu auras moins de torts
allemand de fond quoi
donc moi rien qu'à cause de ça je me
classe dans les hétérodoxes du vous
l'impression que j'ai
ce qui recoupe des trucs qui se passent
aussi dans d'autres domaines notamment
en mathématiques appliquées en
particulier en machine learning
c'est le fait qu' on attend ça donnait
beaucoup de valeur à des modèles dont on
peut prouver des théorèmes on va dire
notamment ce que tu disais sur les
fonctions concave l'idée que que chaque
nouvelle grâce nous apporte moins que
que la précédente
ça c'est dit mathématiquement c'est des
belles fonctions et on peut souvent
montré plein de théorèmes avec assise
tout ce couple bien on peut démontrer
l'unicité par exemple d'un équipe et
tout ça et ça ça fait plaisir ça fait
sérieux ça fait c'était essayer un petit
peu peut-être à une certaine tradition
de d2 de rigueur extrême j'appelle ça un
peu le bourbaki cement en mathématiques
c'est à dire l'idée qu' il faut achat ou
qu'on dit un truc vous que ce soit un
truc solide qui part de fondations
d'axiome très solide ou à dire où tout
cas très simple et très très bien
identifiés par opposition à des
approches si je comprends bien la
méthode hétérodoxes qui sont un peu plus
voilà on va construire le modèle à
partir des données quand on est donné on
va essayer de trouver un modèle qui
colle un peu aux données qui est
vraiment une approche très machine
learning tres tres on est facile en
terre en termes prédictif c'est pas
clair que la première approche qui osera
de meilleurs trucs que la deuxième voilà
alors en plus le problème des modèles
macroéconomiques c'est qu'ils sont peu
prédictif au final
donc on va leur reprocher d'avoir loupé
des crises on va leur reprocher de farce
à la grèce par exemple les modèles
disait c'est bon l'austérité agréé va
s'en sortir - elle s'en est pas sorti
donc il ya il ya tout un problème
derrière c'est que les modèles ne sont
pas prédictifs et on a tendance à dire
bon alors on va essayer de trifouiller
ce truc l'un ou trifouiller ce bidule
mais jamais on se dit et si on partait
sur une base complètement différente
ça donnerait l'impression de 2,2 de
mettre à la poubelle
deux cents ans de recherches économiques
en quelque sorte le truc c'est que ça
s'est construit moi je vois ça comme une
alors peut-être geither mais je vois ça
vraiment comme une espèce de pyramide
c'est à dire il ya certains penseurs
qu'ont mis les bases et ensuite les gens
ont construit par dessus comme ça un
édifice très complexe très haut qu'on
appellerait donc cette théorie orthodoxe
et le problème c'est que le problème
c'est les bases en fait le problème
c'est juste les fondements on part du
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise comment elle
se comporte qu'est ce qu'un homme
comment il faut comprendre pourquoi on
prendrait pas on mettrait pas une base
différente et les deux pourraient très
bien être complémentaires mais remettre
en question cette base c'est revenir
deux cents ans en arrière tu vois dans
le dans les raisonnements
après j'ai un truc que j'aimerais
préciser c'est que donc moi j'ai
mentionné un modèle hétérodoxes mais
c'est pas la seule façon de penser par
je mentionne équine qui a tendance à
regarder les données un peu brute et
c'est vrai qu'il a une inspiration un
peu machine learning et touil
s'intéressent beaucoup aussi à la
physique etc
il s'intéresse aux modèles
météorologiques lycée de comprendre il
veut nécessairement multiplier les
variables entre elles il se dit
l'économie c'est un truc et complexes
avec des points d'équilibré qui peuvent
être multiples ils vont tourner autour
de certains points d'équilibré d'un coup
qui vont se retrouver propulsé un autre
endroit que c'est ça qui va créer les
crises etc
donc il une vision que je trouve
intéressante il yad'autres hétérodoxes
qui vont penser les choses très
différemment par exemple la question qui
à la base de la théorie orthodoxe c'est
comment on fait pour mettre en place un
pour mettre en place une structure au
sein de laquelle chaque individu peut
maximiser son utilité dans les
meilleures conditions
mais il y a des
donc c'est ça la question au coeur de la
théorie économique mais il va y avoir
d'autres penseurs qui vont aborder
choses différemment qui vont dire
comment on fait pour maximiser le pib
par exemple si tu poses une question
différente tutu abouti à quelque chose
de différent
comment je fais pour minimiser le
chômage là je pose une question
différente et donc encore une fois le
jeu comprend pas pourquoi on peut pas
avoir une multiplicité des approches et
des questions posées et tout ça ça doit
être lié derrière à mon avis ben ça doit
être lié à de la politique et c'est là
où moi au début je voulais pas faire le
lien mais maintenant je suis obligé de
faire le lien cercle des organisations
il y en a eu des tas même si tu regardes
les pharaons ça marchait différemment
c'est les rois ça marchait différemment
on avait une société qui était à peu
près stable qui marchait avec des gens
qui crevait pas tous toujours de faim là
ça a l'air de marcher plus ou moins bien
et c'était pas capitaliste et c'était
pas l'offre et la demande mais c'était
pas il ya toujours eu un peu de des
histoires de marchands mais à des degrés
divers donc là de dire que la manière
dont on a organisé les choses c'est la
seule manière je vois pas où est ce
qu'on va chercher ça quand tu dis le mot
politique tu penses à l'organisation de
la société
exactement exactement l'organisation de
la société il ya une espèce de dents
dans le mode de pensée
comment orthodoxe il n'empêche que 1 des
axiomes sait que la meilleure façon de
fixer la valeur des choses c'est de
laisser les gens libres de donner leur
avis sur tout donc une espèce de allah
et en plus alors on va rapprocher sa de
la démocratie on peut mais c'est une
démocratie proportionnel à la taille de
ton portefeuille
c'est à dire que plus tu es riche plus
qu à tombeau à dire puisque moi quand
j'achète une glace le simple fait
d'acheter une glace peut faire varier le
prix de la glace mais évidemment si j'ai
le pouvoir d'acheter 10 millions de
glace jeunes impact beaucoup plus le
prix donc plus je suis pauvre - l'impact
est plus chéri de plus d'impact voilà
évidemment il ya le côté offre aussi
c'est à dire que si j'ai déjà de
l'argent je peux mettre à fabriquer une
usine de glace et chiba dessous je peux
pas donc je ne peux pas impacter le côté
offre mais il ya une liberté
d'entreprendre
même le pauvre peut se lancer si il est
vraiment vaillant dans la construction
d'une usine de glace voilà tout le monde
a un peu le droit de faire comme il veut
et que c'est ça la confrontation des
intérêts des uns et des autres ce qu'ils
veulent vendre les glaces qui veulent le
vendre le plus cher possible
celle qui veut ceux qui veulent acheter
les glaces qui veulent qu'ils veulent
les acheter le moins cher possible
qui va permettre de trouver la vraie
valeur de la glace et ça ben c'est
pareil c'est un c'est un axiome ca c'est
une idée qui a un sens mais je vois pas
en quoi ce serait la seule façon
déterminée le prix de la glace on
pourrait envisager une autre méthode
avec des experts du goût qui goûte la
glace et qui finissent par arracher pas
donner un prix on peut imaginer ce qu'on
veut quoi tu vois je sais pas si tu
comprends pas ce que je veux dire du
coup est-ce que tu joues tu critiques
cette méthode orthodoxe parce qu'elle
est trop populaire ou parce que tu
penses qu'elle est vraiment
problématique
non je vais tourner alors déjà déjà je
pense que
il ya plusieurs choses la première chose
c'est que je critique cette méthode
orthodoxe parce que je trouve que l a
restreint les possibilités
elle devrait elle il ya un champ des
possibles qui est beaucoup plus large
qui me semble beaucoup plus large et la
méthode orthodoxe a tendance à
restreindre les choses ça déjà ça ne va
pas du point de vue de la connaissance
tu vois si tu veux essayer de progresser
dans la connaissance tu peux pas te
mettre des oeillères comme ça il ya
maintenant on sait que le marché que le
marché ça déjà ça me va pas ensuite la
deuxième chose c'est que cette méthode
orthodoxe particulièrement au niveau
macro économique elle est aussi teintée
d'idéologie politique qui le problème
c'est que on va essayer de faire croire
aux gens on va faire croire aux gens
qu'il ya qu un seul mode de pensée et du
coup là là c'est une critique qui est
plus on n'est plus dans le domaine de la
connaissance on est dans le domaine de
de la politique
moi je vais avoir des idées et on va
m'expliquer que mes idées ça marche pas
toutes façons tu vois juste pour un
side-car était donc puisque grand
creuset politique c'était vraiment
l'organisation de la société
quand tu parles d'idéologie politique
c'est qu'est ce que tu entends
exactement bain par exemple que la
liberté individuelle est plus importante
que les valeurs d'égalité que des
jugements de valeur
voilà sur ce que c'est voilà sur ce que
sur ce que devrait être la bonne société
il ya une espèce de l'ambivalence entre
eux enfin c'est entre comment comment je
vais réussir à vialas il ya il ya
plusieurs sociétés possible et on
pourrait analyser on pourrait essayer
d'analyser objectivement commente en
fonction de ce qu'on veut on veut une
société égalitaire
bon voilà à peu près quel genre de
machine économique on pourrait penser
pour avoir une société égalitaire on
veut une société de la liberté voilà à
peu près quel genre de mécanique
économique on pourrait mettre en place
pour avoir une société de la liberté
individuelle
on voudrait et c'est donc pour moi ça
fonctionne non sens l'aserc d'abord les
gens doivent se décider sur ce qu'ils
veulent comme type de société ensuite on
raisonne sur la mécanique qu'on pourrait
mettre en place pour obtenir cette
société
le problème c'est que le raisonnement
économique a tendance à dire maintenant
les gars il n'y a qu'une seule société
possible c'est la mécanique actuelle la
mécanique actuelle est plutôt basé sur
une société de la liberté individuelle
donc vos histoires d'égalité ou de
n'importe quoi donc vous pourriez penser
ça ne peut pas exister ça c'est un point
qui est pas mal discuté par david rioux
mlle philosophes du xviiie siècle qui
parle de la séparation entre l'aspect
descriptif de des théories et l'aspect
l'aspect normatif ou prescriptif des
tories s'est alors qu'il ya des choses
des théories qu'on n'utilise pour
essayer de décrire ou prédire ou essayer
de voir quelque chose qui qui qui parle
de ce qui est ou de ce qui sera et puis
d'autres théories qui se parlent de ce
qu'ils devraient être
et donc là si tu t'excuses est en train
de faire c'est une distinction entre pas
ce que tu dis c'est que fo à faire
davantage cette distinction est que la
partie normatif faudra doivent davantage
il pensait séparément de l'aspect
descriptif mais que s'il reprend enfin
dit moi si je me trompe mais j'ai eu
apparemment dans beaucoup de modèles
économiques les deux sont un petit peu
mélangés et c'est pas très clair qu elle
exactement ti exactement mais il ya
aussi un point qui est important c'est
que le donc ce qui devrait être enfin il
ya une espèce de circularité c'est à
dire que tu peux très bien pensé comment
comment je vais réussir à expliquer ça
il ya une circularité avec la science
économique qui est qui est un peu
malsaine serre que à force de répéter
aux gens que c'est que ça c'est que il
ya que ce matelas qui peut fonctionner
ils finissent par se comporter
exactement de cette manière là et donc
du coup tu fini par dire vous voyez
j'avais raison c'est effectivement ça la
naturalité delà de la fin
il ya une espèce de nature humaine qui
s'exprime par le biais du libéralisme
donc c'est la seule voie possible etc
mais là on rentre dans le domaine de la
delà des sciences humaines serre que les
comportements humains ils sont ils sont
malléables et en fonction du cadre que
tu leur donnes ils vont s'orienter d'une
manière ou d'une autre
playa de circularité et d'ailleurs il ya
certains et donc c'est dommage j'ai
jamais réussi à retrouver cette
situation que j'avais déjà lu on nous
donnait un économiste qui qui
s'opposaient un scientifique
le scientifique disait on décrit la
nature et l'économie disait non
notre rôle c'est aussi de penser la
nature et donc il ya il ya cette volonté
de bain je vais d'abord penser une bonne
société je vais penser la mécanique qui
doit fonctionner au sein de cette bonne
société je vais l'imposer à la société
comme ça je vais obtenir le résultat
désiré de ma bonne société que j'avais
imaginé on s'est perdus on s'est perdu
dans ce truc là c'est une c'est une
boucle quoi c'est causes conséquences
comme conséquence on s'est perdu là
dedans et je crois que dans là en
voulant voir forcément l'économie
une science dure notamment la
macroéconomie comme une science dure
avec des modèles macroéconomiques etc et
les histoires d'inflation les histoires
d'offre et de demande et l'histoire d'
équilibre du marché pense qu'on s'est
complètement
on s'est complètement on a on a
restreint notre champ de vision par
rapport à l'ensemble des possibles non
seulement tu pas certain vraiment pas
sûr que le modèle macroéconomique actuel
décrivent correctement la manière dont
la main dans la mécanique fonctionne
actuellement
mais en plus de ça politiquement
derrière elle va elle va elle va forcer
un peu des politiques à se servir de ce
genre de deux d'analysé de la société
pour dire que c'est la seule société
possible et on se retrouve emprisonnée
dans un dans un système et les questions
sont très importantes aujourd'hui
notamment quand on parle de
réchauffement climatique
2 comment est le problème de pollution
ou même d'énergie de ressources sert
concours vers la croissance et la
croissance économique etc etc alors que
l'on sait très bien que bah oui il ya un
vrai souci
il ya un vrai souci il faudrait
peut-être mettre un objectif différent
mais les modèles actuels sont incapables
de mettre un objectif différent alors
que nous on peut très bien envisager une
société qui recherchent autre chose que
la croissance mais les modèles
économiques en sont incapables
et donc du coup on on en est incapable
c'est c'est assez bizarre le fait qu'il
y ait des choses que le modèle
économique sur des visions du monde que
le modèle économique ne décrit pas fait
qu' on ne les envisage pas en fait on ne
les envisage pas concrètement alors que
chacun dans notre coin on les envisage
ces sacs
ça fait penser à votre truc justement on
y avait beaucoup de gens vous dire par
exemple que le fait de penser unia de
niveau humain ça jamais été prouvé ça
rentre pas dans le cadre de la méthode
scientifique classique et que du coup ne
leur rythme l'envisagent pas même pas
cette possibilité
donc c'est peut-être un billet sur
lesquels on a tendance à ne pas prendre
l'étendue de notre ignorance et essayez
d'imaginer des choses que ne décrivent
pas ce que notre langage n'est pas
capable de décrire ouais ça rapporte 1
c'est vrai je pense que ça peut ça peut
sûrement se rapprocher de ça c'est à
dire et c'est un truc est courant en
intelligence artificielle d'avoir des
gens qui qui questionne fakih qui
rejette la possibilité d'une
intelligence article de niveau humain en
tout cas je suis c'est assez courant
enfin c'est malheureusement fin
malheureusement ce que c'est je vais pas
mal de débats engagés sur twitter autour
de ça et il ya pas mal de chercheurs
français reconnus qui rejette la
possibilité de fonds notamment il ya une
série de trois livres qui que j'ai reçu
récemment qui voilà qui sont très
sceptiques vis-à-vis d'une intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain voire qui
rejette complètement la possibilité que
ça vienne vous qui se voit le jour un
jour et puis l'un des gros problèmes
c'est justement quand on parle de 20
quand je parle en particulier
d'intelligence artificielle de niveau
humain j'ai l'impression de parler pas
quelque chose qui n'est pas dans le
langage de qui je parle et qui du coup
c'est très difficile de
d'attirer leur attention de ne pas
paraître un peu pour un fou ainsi demain
on a une intelligence artificielle de
niveau humain il sort acteur a revu ses
noirs d'autres trucs sur lesquels deux
joueurs au bonheur c'est le fait que tu
disais que je suis fâché publie
exactement ce que tu disais mais l'une
des raisons potentielles pour laquelle
c'est très difficile de sortir de ce
d'une façon de penser c'est je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on me servent pas
mal aussi dans les sciences typiquement
penser en dehors du cadre du thonier les
pommes d'einstein
justin maurice greene c'était très très
difficile et en particulier avec la
machine learning
pendant mon temps à les trucs dit d'un
ton certes israël n'était pas du machine
learning et c'était assez bizarre de
penser enfin moi je me moquer
ouvertement des enfin pas trop
ouvertement mais je me moquais quand
même des réseaux de neurones en 2011
parce que c'était tellement pas aussi
beau mathématiques donc que les autres
objets que je manipulais s'était pas
qu'on veut avec ce n'est pas tout genre
et ça ça fait aussi que parce que du
coup il ya un peu flirté avec le monde
un petit peu dans la puce d'un micro
économie ce qui est des modèles à ses
proches à ses mateu et l'impression que
j'ai pas mal dans le monde de la
recherche sais c'est que lorsque surtout
quand on est étudiant en thèse avec vous
cherchez à faire ses preuves on essaie
de montrer qu'on est bon parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on a un boulot et qu'on
raisonne l'académie sinon celui sur tech
et que du coup il ya une pression assez
de montrer que tu es que tes pompes et
pour montrer que tu es bon bah tu prends
les modèles des gens les modèles
populaires qui ont bien marché et tu
montres que tu les as compris et puis tu
rajoutes une pierre à l'édifice en
prouvant un théorème et en plus si les
fondations sont très mathématique tu
peux prouver les toiles que tu peux
prouver montrer que tu es intelligent et
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un peu de
surenchère de ceux de sable juste parce
que tout le monde veut montrer qu'il est
bon c'est comme ça qu'on survit dans
l'académie mais qui du coup favorise les
modèles axiomatique
c'est peut-être une raison pour laquelle
le l'économie orthodoxe est encore aussi
populaire
oui ça se peut ça fait complètement
c'est un des indes est un des billets
qui est le mien et qui me fait me poser
tous leurs pleins de questions et me
remettre en question et tu sais c'est
que moi je ne suis pas docteur en
économie j'ai pas j'ai pas fréquenter ce
milieu de la recherche
donc je sais pas bien comment ils
fonctionnent et met donc c'est
intéressant d'avoir ton point de vue
parce que parce que c'est une question
pour moi qui revient systématiquement
systématiquement systématiquement je
n'arrive pas à comprendre que des gens
qui sont beaucoup plus intelligents que
moi et qu'on cherchait dans un domaine
en particulier arrive pas à se rendre
compte de ce que moi j'ai l'impression
d'avoir compris et donc du coup
systématiquement c est ce que c'est moi
qui ai compris de travers ou ou est ce
que c'est
ou est-ce que c'est nécessairement entre
les deux ou pas ou et vais donc donc je
continue d'essayer de me poser un
maximum de questions en tout cas pour
l'instant dans mon raisonnement
non je n'arrive pas et d'ailleurs
voilà on en parle et donc il ya des gens
qui écouteront probablement ce podcast
et donc c'est un truc et c'est difficile
pour moi de d'en arriver à l'exprimer
voilà mais j'en suis suffisamment sûre
aujourd'hui pour me dire ok bah tant pis
je le dis peut-être que je changerais
d'avis et je vous changerez d'avis si ça
arrive je vois les gens par la russie
mais pour l'instant mais non je j'ai
beau chercher non après d'un point de
vue bayésiens c'est pas grave d'avoir
plusieurs modèles compatibles c'est même
quelque chose d'assez désirable et de
comparer les prédictions et puis si
elles sont convergentes sur un point
vraiment confiance en ce point que je
pense que c'est du coup intéressant
d'avoir une diversité de modèles mais
c'est pour ça ça vaut de revenir à la
question que j'allais poser mais qui a
été le fait que
s'il y avait zéro pour cent des
économistes qui étaient orthodoxe
j'aurais tendance à défendre cette
position enfin s'il y avait 1 % des
économies qui sera votée orthodoxe parce
que cette violence thématique permet de
dire des choses
j'imagine en tout cas en tout cas permet
vous tracer une voie différente et du
coup peut-être que c'est plus simple
le fait que ce soit à ce point populaire
qui se soucie c'est peut-être ça qui est
dérangeant que alors moi ce qui ce qui
me l'aller les jeux je peux que faire
que si tu es ce que j'entends sur les
raisons de la popularité de cette
orthodoxie
c'est notamment le fait que ça te permet
d'avoir les meilleurs boulots ça te
permet d'avoir les meilleurs c'est alors
que d'abord d'abord il ya une manière
dont l'économie est enseigné l'économie
est enseignée au travers du prisme de
l'économie orthodoxe donc on ne
mentionne pas trop les autres façons de
penser
on mentionne cette façon de penser c'est
enseigner comme une science donc ça en
général ce que les gens disent et
jusqu'au master on te parle que
d'économie orthodoxe dont il ya toute
une pas d'un panel de gens qui sont bac
+5 en économie qui se retrouve un peu
lâchés dans la nature qui vont obtenir
des postes etc et qui eux ont vu les
choses que au travers de cet angle là
donc ils sont même pas au coin où à
peine qu'il ya autre chose
donc est ce que eux on les considère
dans les sondages ou pas et si oui
forcément eux ont leur on leur a pas
demandé d'essayer de réfléchir un peu
maintenant ils sont dans un poste il
applique ce qu'ils ont vu à l'école
voilà et après il ya ceux qui vont au
delà ce qu'ils vont faire un doctorat et
là effectivement c'est ça devient plus
vaste mais il n'empêche que il faut que
ce soit à propre volonté de dire bon
maintenant que j'ai appris l'économie
orthodoxe je vais m'intéresser à jeu par
kaka kane c'est vraiment au modèle
keynésien ou alors je mets ma marque ou
à la porte et forcément si tu dis ben
non je vais m'intéresser
je vais essayer d'aller plus loin dans
le modèle orthodoxe ben voila tu restes
toujours dans le prix sans jamais avoir
vu autre chose non plus donc l'idée
c'est qu'il ya une espèce de biais comme
ça parce que l'économie est enseigné de
cette manière là et ben tout le monde se
retrouve
on a une majorité de gens qui pensent
orthodoxe bon alors est-ce que c'est
correct je sais pas il ya un autre truc
aussi c'est quand arrivait que tu dis
moi j'ai un modèle marxiste absolument
génial et que tu veux un job dans un
ministère on va peut-être te dire dans
mes mecs
voilà on n'est pas dans un système
marxiste on est dans un système libéral
donc nous on veut des économistes
libéraux qui peuvent nous donner des
idées de comment faire fonctionner cette
machine libérale afin néolibérale con
con donc est-ce que ça aussi le biais
les gens se forment en se disant ben
voila moi comme je disais tout à l'heure
je vais être un outil pour une
entreprise ou pour un théâtre utile
donc si je suis spécialiste d'un truc
qui n'existe pas c'est l'intérêt à dire
ça renvoie aussi à deux trucs en
mathématique puisque les mathématiques
qui sont enseignées post bac sont des
mathématiques de la théorie des
ensembles un bon tu vas pas me dire
qu'il ya plusieurs mathématiques à 6 il
ya plusieurs intérêts j'aime pas trop a
été ensemble c'est pas que c'est mal
c'est qu'il est typiquement un lâche là
je pense pour le coût 80 et 95 % on va
dire des mathématiciens son ensemble
estime à dire ah ouais je n'insulte pas
c'est très bien mais je pense qu'il ya
des théories des types en particulier
tout jeune aussi c'est pour sa météo
était type
je préfère c'est un côté plus
algorithmique et j'aime bien ça mais bon
j'excuse tous les 95% dhabi
mathématicien surtout ceux qui croient à
l'exception sais c'est pas grave tu sais
qu'il ya un truc qui reçoit fréquemment
dans les discussions quand enfin dans
les débats c'est mais tu peux pas être
contre ça c'est mathématique
en plus c'est assez vrai faux par ci par
là c'est comme les gens qui disent que
voilà le changement climatique c'est
aussi vrai que le théorème de pythagore
je veux dire j'espère que ça allait un
peu plus que le terme de pete ailleurs à
ce que le terme de pythagore et pas tout
à fait vrai qu'en dire l'univers est un
espace-temps courbes et que du coup un
triangle rectangle
l'histoire des plots zippo tennis
accardi protéger tout ça marche très
très bien au grain oui voilà
bon ça c'est pas mal aussi ça me rassure
de savoir que il fut pas la fin que que
fabre mais on n'est pas du tout le
niveau mais ça me rassure de savoir que
même en mathématiques potentiellement il
ya des désaccords et que les désaccords
et thématiques aussi bien sûr qu'elle
mathématiques cher mais du coup est ce
que tu as eu l'occasion de pas mal
d'avoir des discussions intéressantes au
mans avec des orthodoxes et ben non pas
tant que ça c'est aussi un énorme biais
il faut qu'il faudrait que j'arrive à
[Musique]
lui arrive à compenser serre j'ai
discuté un peu avec eux un tout petit
peu pas bon on a échangé par message
avec un doctorant je sais pas si les
doctorants docteurs maintenant qu'à
travailler notamment sur la chaîne de
stupide economics ils étaient ils
n'étaient pas d'accord avec moi sur sur
certaines vidéos et il m'a fait des
messages un peu et j'ai essayé de
comprendre son sombre de raisonnement
mais non mais j'étais c'était pas
d'accord avec lui lui me disait que la
science progresse que c'est vraiment
l'économie c'est une science
alors il ya aussi une distinction à
faire c'est que donc moi encore une fois
à chaque fois que dit l'économie il faut
entendre macroéconomique toi je sais je
suis tout à fait suffisant pour cent
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya des gens qui
s'intéressent à des mécanismes très
précis et qu'ils vont trouver un truc
très précis t il n'y a pas de souci moi
là là là le hétérodoxes orthodoxe j'aime
et c'est uniquement au niveau
macroéconomique que je les classe
ok donc voilà c'est tout mais donc ce
que ce que veut dire cette personne
c'est non il ya des labos d'économies
avec des gens qui travaillent vraiment
qu'ils font des expériences réelles
et voilà et les expériences on essaye de
les reproduire et c'est tout le
processus scientifiques classiques qui
est mis en place et avant de dire que
c'est une nouvelle connaissance bah
ouais on a on a testé on a vérifié on
il n'y a pas de raison d'être hétérodoxe
et encore le faire donc moi je suis pas
d'accord parce que parce que dont déjà
le lui ai pas macroéconomistes alors que
moi c'est c'est vraiment ce domaine là
qui m'intéressent et je suis désolé
quand tu vois un modèle un modèle
dynamique
comment les dies dit là donc c'est le
modèle dynamique stochastique équilibre
général
alors j'en ai pas regardé un dans le
détail mais met donc les descriptions
que j'envoyais non je suis désolé je
vois pas il n'y a pas de système
bancaire il n'y a pas de monnaie il n'y
a pas de création monétaire il ya oui ok
mais ça me paraît être une description
vraiment très très parcellaire de ski
est là de ce qu'est l'économie de ce qui
est notre monde et aussi sa limite
forcément les les actions c'est ça aussi
qui me pose problème
par exemple dans un modèle d'équilibré
général il n'y a pas de chômage
par défaut le seul moyen d'avoir du
chômage c'est d'organiser des
frottements donc on peut imaginer
l'espèce de rouages et dans les rouages
un moment donné tu vas avoir des rouages
qui sont grippés et c'est le fait que ce
soit grippe et qui va générer du chômage
donc solution pour dégripper tout ça eh
ben il faut remettre de l'huile dans le
moteur quoi en quelque sorte et l'huile
dans le moteur du point de vue de ses
modèles lacets il faut flexibiliser
l'emploi il faut il faut des règles qui
soient plus simples il faut faire en
sorte que l'offre et la demande soit
connecté de manière le plus dynamique
possible donc il faut des plateformes en
ligne il faut essayer de voilà on rentre
dans un peu les réformes
macron est en train de faire passer ou
alors les lois hartz en allemagne qui
sont à ces fameuses qui ont été passées
par schröder etc où il a vraiment
flexibiliser le marché de l'emploi de ça
pour l'idée c'était ça un cg un modèle
qui me dit que il faut mettre de l'huile
dans les rouages et donc le moyen de
mettre de l'huile c'est de rendre tout
plus souple en fait il faut pas qui est
trop de choses trop rigide mais le truc
c'est que par construction le modèle ne
peut pas expliquer le chômage autrement
que par un problème de rigidité donc
nécessairement la seule solution qui va
proposer aux politiques
c'est à flexibiliser mais ça va pas
parce qu'il ya des analyses du chômage
qui peuvent se baser sur des tas
d'autres choses pourraient très bien
dire qu'en fait le chômage le problème
une problématique du chômage ce serait
dire voilà on a besoin d'une certaine
quantité de marchandises pour vivre et
il se trouve que pour produire cette
quantité de marchandises
on a besoin que de 15 personnes or on
est 30 voilà donc du coup ça marche pas
bien pas besoin de tout le monde
du coup il ya un chevalement ça le
modèle est pas capable de te le dire ils
ne l'envisagent pas donc forcément
toutes ces questions là sont en dehors
du spectre on les pose même pas et on
pourrait il y en a il pourrait y en
avoir des tas d'autres
donc je vois encore une fois ses choix
j'ai vraiment parce que il ya quand même
pas mal ce qui est une vidéo de stupide
économique ce qui paraît justement de du
de l'automatisation par les machines et
du chômage et qui défendent la thèse
selon laquelle il y aura plus deux ans
il y aura pas de enfin il y aura pas de
prime de chômage même s'il y avait une
auto mef
car ils savaient pas poser de problème
de chômage le fait qu'ils essaient et
automatisation paris machines et du coup
dans la vidéo stupide économique
ci-dessus billets économiques s'il
opposait la vision à ce qu'il appelait
des technologistes et versus des
économistes ou disait qu' il ya des
technologistes pense qu'il y aura du
chômage massif potentiellement tout cas
à cause d'eux des machines et les
économistes disait tout cas d'après la
vidéo de stupide économique ce qu' il
n'y aura jamais de deux mois de chômage
massif en tout cas structurels comme ça
à cause de l'automatisation et c'est une
tension qui a c'est assez étrange qui
est une tension aussi forte entre ces
deux de mieux que ouais à toi les
économistes donc moi je ne comprends pas
que les économistes peuvent pas se poser
la question de mais pourquoi le travail
parce qu'on a besoin du travail
est-ce qu'on est fait pour travailler
est ce que oui non peut-être pas
peut-être qu'en fait il ya une espèce de
volonté de deux j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya une espèce de volonté de toute façon
il faut qu'il y ait du travail
sinon si on s'arrache plus l'économie
marche plus non on les connaît on va
marcher même centre enfin son travail
humain on pourrait penser
donc ouais ouais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être du coup quelque chose qui
juste rentre pas dans le modèle et comme
on a l'habitude de raisonner dans ce
modèle c'est difficile d'envisager la
possibilité que kylie à un chômage
structurel
elles sont en a parlé d'expérience qui
étaient mentionnés par
par olivier si c'était quoi comme
expérience et ce que j'ai du mal à
imaginer des expériences en
macroéconomie donc je ne sais pas je
sais pas je ne sais pas
il m'a proposé dans un de ces messages
d'avoir accès un laboratoire de
recherche en économie pour que je me
rende compte par moi-même et j'ai pas
j'ai pas relevé le truc c'est
probablement c'est de ma faute aussi non
j'ai pas je suis pas allé plus loin
après c'est un peu compliqué on est pas
on n'habite pas au même endroit mais en
plus de ça je suis pas sûr que lui me
parler d'expérience en macroéconomie
cela que vous parlez de 6 ans mais donc
moi encore une fois c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse moi c'est la macroéconomie
qui m'intéresse c'est pas la
microéconomie donc le fait de dire je
vais aller dans une entreprise je vais
tester ça je vais dans une entreprise
similaire je vais tester ça et je vais
voir le résultat d'accords très bien
fine moi la question c'est la manière
dont les deux entreprises fonctionnent
c'est pas la seule manière possible
on pourra envisager d'autres manières
dont les entreprises fonctionnent et du
compte du coût du coup on n'est pas sur
le domaine sur même niveau de
questionnements en fait et donc ça
m'amène à ce que tu disais il ya un
petit bouton maintenant mais tu disais
que du coup la méthode scientifique tu
voyais pas comment elle pouvait
s'appliquer en tueur était de plus en
plus dubitatif à l'idée d'appliquer les
méthodes scientifiques l économie ou
j'imagine plutôt sa macro économie en
tout cas qu'est ce que tu entends par
méthode scientifique
bah ouais alors c'est pas évident je
suis pas un expert donc je vais essayer
de de redire correctement ce que
j'entends sur les chaînes des et
éthicien met donc oui pour moi pour moi
il ya un côté assez il faut pouvoir donc
effectué il faut pouvoir faire des
expériences
il faut voir les refaire on retombe sur
les même résultats et l'objectif c'est
d'essayer de décrire le réel c'est un
peu comme ça que je le vois donc mais je
ne ne peux pas envisager la méthode
scientifique dans le cadre
macroéconomique donc je vais prendre un
exemple jeu
je prends une pomme elle tombe par terre
je me demande pourquoi elle tombe par
terre je commence à faire des mesures je
regarde la vitesse je me dis tiens
alors elle met autant de temps à tomber
puis si je la mets un peu plus elle
mettra tant de temps à tomber etc etc
et puis finalement j'essaie de décrire
le mouvement de la pomme et je remplace
la pomme par une clé à molette et je
regarde si ça se passe pareil etc
mais au bout d'un moment je vais aboutir
une espèce de théories qui va
normalement décrire ce qui va se passer
et donc à la fin une fois que j'ai des
crises qui j'ai ma théorie est bien je
demande à des gens de venir et je leur
dis ok allez-y proposer moins un truc
elle vais vous dire à l'avant ce qui va
se passer
alors ça implique forcément la chute
d'un corps alors le mec va dire voilà je
prends ce cerf-volant je le lâche qu'est
ce qui se passe alors à temps je mesure
toutes les dimensions mon cerveau lange
le passe dans mon modèle et je te dis le
cerf-volant il devrait faire ça on le
lâche et on regarde ce qui se passe et
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai on fait un
nombre suffisant d'expérience et au fur
et à mesure on arrive à se rencontrent
si la théorie approche semble décrire à
peu près correctement le réel sachant
que j'ai vu la dernière vidéo de
monsieur fit sur wii où il parlait
justement de cette option est ce que on
décrit correctement la mécanique de la
montre qu est-ce qu on approche
seulement la mécanique de l'amour bon
peu importe à la limite on arrive à on
arrive à prédire ce qui va se passer
donc moi je remets absolument passer en
question je trouve que c'est une bonne
méthode ça me semble intuitivement en
tout cas est une bonne méthode pour
décrire le réel on répète les
expériences un nombre suffisant de fois
pour être sûr mais je ne vois pas
comment on peut le faire en
macroéconomie c'est impossible
il nous faudrait des planètes terre
d'expérience comme ça avec 18 mains
dedans alors un coup on fait ça quand on
fait ça on fait ça et on regarde comment
ça se passe ça n'a aucun sens puisque
peut se demander si c'est souhaitable de
le faire parce qu'il ya des plaintes 30
ans des trucs vraiment bizarre seulement
m mais on est une simulation il ya des
mecs qui nous regarde où il dispute un
libéralisme faut je suis à l'air de bien
marcher mais ça fait des trucs bizarres
quand même réussi donc
donc voilà c'est si ça se trouve enfin
je vois pas comment c'est applicable
comment la méthode scientifique est
applicable au niveau macroéconomique
tout ce qu'on peut voir tout ce qu'on
peut faire encore une fois à mon sens
c'est essayer de regarder ce qui se
passe
donc on a mis en place un cadre c'est
nous qui avons choisi ce cadre donc ce
cadre on peut le changer mais admettons
on l'a mis en place et maintenant ce que
les économistes peuvent faire c'est
essayer de regarder comment le cadre à
fonctionner
comment l'économie a fonctionné dans le
passé avec certaines règles et essayer
d'en déduire un mode de fonctionnement
en disant bon si vous gardez le même
cadre a priori pense que ça pourrait
partir comme ci comme ça mais du coup ça
ne remet pas en question le fait que le
cadre on peut le changer à n'importe
quel moment et que du coup les économies
sera obligé de reprendre tout l'art
moderne le dire ok ils ont tout changé à
leurs photos reprendre sa marche plus
comme ça les gars on est en voilà et
aussi ça ne change pas le fait que
finalement la méthode un peu la méthode
macroéconomique c'est comme ça qu'elle
essaye de ce que de faire faire que le
cadre change un peu pas trop et puis
elle essaye d'en déduire les modes de
fonctionnement et de prédire l'avenir et
déjà comme ça elle est très peu
prédictive en tout cas les modèles
actuels sont très peu prédictif et ça
c'est assez problématique pour le coup
parce que autant bon comme tu le sais je
suis pas le plus grand défenseur de la
méthode scientifique en tout cas est
telle que tu l'a décrite et et que du
coup c'est pas grave si on peut pas
faire des expériences répétées mais
autant par contre
avoir un aspect au moins partiellement
prédictif c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez important il me semble ok il
faut que ce soit partiellement prédictif
et donc c'est pas grave d'avoir des
expériences ne pas avoir des efforts
répétés dit pas ce que je te dis créé
assez c'est absolument pas consensus
même pas dans peace théologie s'effacer
balzani puisque c'est cette idée que tu
vas voir des modèles qui font des
prédictions probabiliste qui sont
capables de dire je sais pas si demain
il fera probablement beau et le pib va
probablement augmenter le cours du
dollar va probablement diminuer ce genre
de prédictions et puis quand il fait
quand il fait un peu comme ça on peut
imaginer avoir plein de théories
différentes et on regarde les scores des
différentes théories au fur et à mesure
en terme de prédiction
et puis on peut appliquer aussi la forme
de baisses directement mais ça donne une
idée du coût de quels sont les théories
sur lesquels on peut plus le plus
s'appuyer pour faire des prédictions à
venir d'accord d'accord le leur ai donc
mais c'est c'est quelque chose d'assez
intéressant ce débat sur la méthode
scientifique parce que un système
intéressant que l'on fait ma série
actuelle met donc c'est cette méthode
scientifique expériences répétées et
tout ça donc ses liens avec eux
ce qu'on appelle le fréquentent isme qui
compte la fréquence est pas qu une
fréquence pour qu'ils répétition on sent
bien le le lien très proche entre le
répéter des expériences et le
fréquentent isme et le truc c'est que
historiquement donc le free kantisme a
été introduit par ona de fisher
notamment en génétique avec ses
expériences qu'il pouvait répéter mais
elle a d'autres qui disait mais moi je
peux je peux pas répéter mes expériences
notamment
moi j'imagine macroéconomistes aurait pu
lui dire ça mais historiquement il y
avait pas mal notamment un géologue qui
disaient ouais c'est bien voter truc
mais moi quand j'observe un séisme mais
je vais pas la répéter comme ça
pour calculer des fréquences que
j'allais français ça effectivement ça
s'applique pas qu'à la macroéconomie et
du coup way
ma remarque ça marche aussi pour la
science du climat non sélection du
climat toutes les sciences historiques
l'histoire de la biologie évolutionnaire
donc si tu veux voir quels sont les
ancêtres communs ben tu peux pas répéter
l'évolution du vivant c'est un peu
compliqué la cosmologie aussi bas
cosmologie tu observes les étoiles tu
peux pas répéter l'univers pour savoir
comment seraient les étoiles dans un
univers alternatif
il ya quand même pas mal de ces domaines
où la répétition d'expérience et pas du
tout
par contre tu peux tu peux bac tester le
modèle n'ont cessé d'expliquer le passé
c'est ça et trouver des modèles qui qui
colle avec ce qu'on observe mais c'est
difficile par contre pas tu peux pas
faire des expériences répétées en tout
cas de façon pragmatique et en tout cas
et du coup c'est assez problématique
parce que du coup ça donne une vision
enfin ça donne l'impression que j'ai
avec les gens qui raisonnent vraiment
par rapport à la répétition des
expériences et tout ça qui sont vraiment
dans la méthode scientifique
c'est peut-être similaire à ce que tu
décris des orthodoxes
c'est le fait qu' ils ont eu cette façon
de penser et c'est difficile parce qu'il
rentre pas dans leur case biseau
tendance un peu à l'ignorer que ça fait
cette fameuse distinction on parle de
démarcation entre les sciences et les
patience et pseudo-sciences si on veut
la paix comme ça où va dans les sciences
il ya ski et répétable par expérience et
tout ça et puis dans le reste bas on a
tendance à se dire bon bah on s'en
préoccupe pas ou si ça vaut pas le coup
comme ça intéresse ou sait même pas de
la science quelque chose comme ça que je
pense que c'est une tension qu'il est
urgent de rétablir et de faire un peu
plus gaffe
comment est-ce qu'on décrit les
approches du savoir mais du coup il ya
des domaines comme ça qu'ils sont
considérés comme des pseudosciences je
pense pas que la cosmologie soit
considérée comme une pseudoscience que
théorie du big bang même la science de
l'essence du climat ou les je pense que
ce qui se passe un peu plus à voir c'est
une question sur laquelle on débat pas
mal avec thibaut avec monsieur fille de
savoir si comment est-ce qu'on peut
chercher à remettre en cause aussi bien
et aussi optimalement que possible le
fait que la méthode scientifique telle
qu'elle est souvent décrite par
tellement beaucoup d'eux et éthicien par
aussi beaucoup de scientifiques y
compris beaucoup de scientifiques rares
connues est bien plus intelligent que
moi
cette méthode scientifique basée sur la
répétition comment est-ce qu'on amène
tous ces gens là finalement à au moins
remettre un peu en cause ce qu'ils
disent
donc thibault lui les plus méthode plus
de pouce quand il essaie de les pousser
à réfléchir davantage à ce qu'ils font
se dire que c'est pas moi je suis plus
méthode coup de poids c'est à dire que
je n'en toi coup de poing à chercher un
peu coup de frein sur ça je préfère dire
aux gens d'arrêter vos bêtises la
méthode scientifique c c'est quand même
pas réduit tout ce qu portes qu'à la
méthode qu'appliquer scientifique n'est
pas du tout la méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle est souvent
décrite et s'est même pas du tout ce qui
est souhaitable de faire c'est quand
même plus et du coup j'ai tendance à
attaquer directement la méthode
scientifique est à dire qu il faut la
remplacer par par par quelque chose plus
adéquat qui est capable de parler des
choses non répétable mais où est-ce
qu'elle est formulée ou est ce qu'elle
est formalisé alors ça c'est un des gros
problèmes si ce que la méthode
scientifique donc je t'ai demandé ce que
tu penses est la méthode scientifique
si j'avais demandé à un autre hymne aura
sans doute répondu quelque chose d'un
peu différent et si j'avais demandé un
scientifique est encore un truc
différent ou êtes éthiciens peut-être
encore un truc un peu différent et c'est
pas très claire de ce que c'est
exactement la méthode scientifique
je pense qu'il faut parler plus tôt des
méthodes scientifiques que de la méthode
scientifique
en tout cas si on parle de des méthodes
déjà faut que je pense qu'on fait la
distinction entre la méthode
qu'appliquent les scientifiques ou les
méthodes qu'appliquent les scientifiques
dans les différents domaines et les
méthodes idéalisée et côté descriptif
ont décrit ce que les scientifiques font
et le côté normatif qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait que les scientifiques face et
même dans la partie normative
il ya en fait il ya plusieurs méthodes
scientifiques qui sont décrites
plusieurs puisque selon les différentes
personnes ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
présenté des méthodes scientifiques
différentes et donc partie descriptive
c'est clairement le cas que voir
quelqu'un qui fait de la biologie va pas
faire la même chose que quelqu'un qui
tue la cosmologie tu vas faire la même
chose que quelqu'un qui étudie les
sciences sociales bouge pas ou
psychologie expérimentale ou ou la
macroéconomie il faudrait donc je pense
que c'est important d'être un petit peu
plus de fait un peu plus gaffe parce
qu'on appelle le
les méthodes scientifiques hockey et
donc du coup elle est formalisée
clairement nulle part par exemple quand
je vois les et éthicien d'hygiène
mentale ou la tronche-en-biais toi tu as
des critiques apportées à skis alors
manière de christophe que j'interviewe
est déjà dans ce podcast crise
christophe a pas mal évolué donc ça se
sent en fait dans ces vidéos si vous
prête un peu d'attention boyer non plus
bas ayant notamment parce qu'il a fait
bannissement récemment est en train de
basculer et web à la tronche-en-biais
mais enfin c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
la tronche-en-biais j'ai pas envie de
critiquer directement mais beaucoup
beaucoup de présentations par des
scientifiques ou par des attitudes et
éthicien de la méthode scientifique me
semble juste très très critiquable
tellement d'autres thibault avait
beaucoup critiqué enfin moi aussi
j'avais critiqué sur twitter mes choix
qui vous l'avez fait en vidéo il avait
critiqué une vidéo de de l'esprit
sorcier sur la méthode scientifique
ouais parce que les trucs qui collait
pas du tout avec la méthode des
scientifiques et qui si on les prenait
sérieusement et qu'on me demandait aux
scientifiques de faire la méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle était exposée
ça serait assez catastrophique il y
aurait des conséquences assez néfaste
sur les résultats des sciences donc
c'est certain que ouais c'est un
problème qui est beaucoup plus
compliquée qu'il n'y paraît et en fait
je pense que le coeur du problème
ça vient d'un de quelque chose d'autres
encore c'est que on a tendance à donner
énormément de valeur à la science et du
coup on a tendance à avoir une approche
un peu plus voilà la sens on sait que
c'est bien comment est-ce qu'on justifie
je pense qu'il ya un raisonnement motivé
que l'on a à vouloir dire que la science
c'est le truc bien et que du coup à six
si jamais la méthode qu'utilise et
scientifique a des problèmes on va dire
ça se passe à la science on va dire la
science sait et on va essayer de te
trouver des raisons de redéfinir la
science pour que ça se passe quelque
chose de bien
c'est un peu pour ça aussi que
typiquement que toutes les sciences
sociales se revendique des sciences
c'est une question basque comme la
science on sait que c'est bien bas vous
dire que la science et des sciences
sociales c'est bien que je pense qu'il
faut un peu dépassé ça que faire un peu
gaffe aux connotations et voyais pas
partir à la quête des connotations
positives et être capable de critiquer
les connotations positives et de
défendre les connotations négatives et
c'est pour ça que moi je suis plus pris
la position de dire dans la science
c'est pas un truc tout cas tel que c'est
souvent décrits ou tel que ça fonctionne
vraiment c'est loin d'être si idéal
c'est certainement ce même clairement
largement meilleur que d'autres méthodes
qui sont pas scientifique mais c'est
loin d'être l'idéal est en fait et en
particulier on s'en fout à la limite de
ce qu'est la science qui a question qui
m'intéresse moi c'est comment est ce
qu'on peut faire pour avoir des modèles
aussi fiable que possible des
prédictions aussi aussi juste que
possible pour les descriptions du monde
aussi adéquate que possible si je pense
que ça devrait être plus ça l'objectif
indépendamment du fait que est-ce qu'on
rentre dans les cases si on secoue donc
la presse car il n'ya pas l'y aurait pas
un problème aussi de
de vocabulaire au final au lieu de
parler de science de parler des
mathématiques de parler de la physique
de parler de la chimie n'est pas dire
les sciences sociales non il ya
l'anthropologie la sociologie il ya la
philosophie il ya après il ya des pros
dia dans les mathématiques tel truc tel
truc tel truc donc pour telle analyse
on utilise tel type de technique pour
autre chose on va utiliser tel au type
de technique etc
il ya une volonté de tête de généraliser
qui est finalement néfastes
ouais je pense qu'il peut avoir aussi l'
inverse que c'est à dire que moi je
pense qu'il y ait des problèmes de de
généralisations excessives mais il ya
aussi des problèmes de
compartimentalisation excessive
on a tendance à confiner certains trucs
alors que parfois il ya clairement de
l'interdisciplinarité qui est nécessaire
et puis il ya aussi même ducale approche
du paysagisme c'est au contraire ça une
vision très très unifiée de toutes les
façons de savoir en fait paul bizien
dans tous ces domaines tous les cas il
ya en fait une façon unifiée de savoir
qui consiste à appliquer la formule bays
et vos des probabilités
en tout cas si je pense que c'est
intéressant souvent de réfléchir à d
parce que bon la tuer
la macroéconomie en fait c'est plus les
problèmes de sk la macroéconomie est une
science remet pas du tout spécifique à
la macroéconomie tout cas beaucoup des
critiques que tu a soulevé me semble pas
du tout spécifique à la macroéconomie
tout cas je pense que ça s'applique
largement à d'autres domaines
[Musique]
enfin iliad sp site est assez
particulière mais il ya beaucoup
d'aspects par exemple le fait que l'on
peut ne pas faire d'expérience ça ça se
retrouve dans d'autres en sismologie ou
cosmologie alors moi j'ai une question
pour toi
comment est ce que tu vis
personnellement le fait de pas d'accord
avec une majorité de tes pairs sur
certains sujets par exemple s'est passé
c'est pas facile
etc c'est pas mal le caresser mais c'est
pas facile serait que ceux typiquement
sur ses idées de dépayser à nice mme je
me sens souvent très seul lancer ça
c'est assez compliqué ce qui me rassure
c'est que à chaque fois que j'en parle
longuement avec des gens je fini par les
convaincre
souvent et mais pop et j'ai souvent des
réactions assez assez c'est assez
virulente de pas mal de gens ce n'est
pas que c'est pas facile
est ce que est ce que t'as pas est ce
que t'as pas parce que est-ce que tu
arrives à convaincre des gens qui sont
experts comme toi ou parce que moi moi
il ya un des grands trucs par exemple ce
serait de discuter avec une personne qui
réfléchit à la macroéconomie mais d'un
point de vue orthodoxe que j'arriverai à
convaincre qu'en fait non j'ai donc j'ai
jamais eu l'occasion et j'ai
l'impression que je n'en serais pas
capable en fait est ce que toi tu crois
que tu en serait capable pour une
personne qui sait ça dépend à quel point
mais je sais pas si je peux l'annoncer
publiquement mais il ya eu un
statisticien de youtube qui est en train
de changer de camp nathan
est en train de plus en plus séduits par
les idées viennent donc c'est un petit
peu ses six premiers fréquente est
vraiment que je comprends c'est pas moi
en fait c'est si j'ai le mental qui
équipe qui l'a convaincu mais après ça
prend du temps comme un attend ça fait
longtemps qu'on lui parle
ça fait plusieurs vidéos sur bèze à nice
qui l'a vu ça prend c'est enfin
clairement en une discussion c'est très
compliqué prendre viendra justement à
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dans une
discussion et je pense que c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire si j'essaie de si
quelqu'un me semble parce qu'en fait
c'est un truc qui arrive très souvent
notamment quand on parle de deux futurs
des intelligences artificielles
je pense qu'il ya clairement un fossé
entre les les gens qui résonne de façon
très bayésienne et les gens qui résonne
de façon plus méthodes scientifiques
classiques qui est que méthodes
scientifiques classiques en attendant
c'est à dire plus je sais pas et ont
tendance à ne pas en parler parce qu'on
ne sait pas donner d'importance à ce
concept
alors qu'un malaisien va je veux essayer
de quantifier un peu l'incertitude et
voilà même si une priorité de 1 % pour
qu'il n'ya de niveau i man
dans les vingt ans à venir dans l'aude
en 2025
comme je défends dans une belle vidéo
ben 1% c'est énorme c'est beaucoup plus
qu'après été qu'un astéroïde énorme qui
tombe sur la terre et il ya des millions
qui sont dépensés dans la détection de
tester ohrid
du coup une façon je donne pas mal
d'importance à ça et je sais plus à ce
que je voulais venir avec ce tout ça
puisque c'est quoi ta question
moi j'avais donc du coup on aurait alors
j'en avais une autre qui venait sans fin
ou plutôt je pose plus précisément ma
question c'est à dire pour un fréquent
tisse alors du coup comme nathan c'est
quoi les arguments qui va mettre en
avant pour ne pas être d'accord avec le
gazier à nice tu sais c'est quoi ces
points où il va dire mais non là parce
que moi quand tu me parles de 2 quand je
regarde les vidéos de nathan par exemple
cessé le chat sceptique c'est c'est
commencer la statistique expliqué à mon
chat j'ai jamais vu nos points de
contradiction entre ce que toi tu
racontais par exemple est-ce que lui
racontait dans ces vidéos alors le gros
point de divergence c'est
on parlera bientôt cesser les préjugés
en fait pour un béziers faut toujours
mettre des probabilités même si on n'a
pas de données
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
difficile à accepter
il ya d'autres aspects un peu lié à ça
c'est le fait que pour un bail vient que
pour voyez y en a qui essaient de dire
que c'est pas le cas mais je suis à peu
près sûr que c'est le cas pour un bail
et bien tout est subjectif
enfin deux cas la subjectivité est
quelque chose de très normal parce que
j'ai pas accès aux mêmes données que toi
du coup on n'a pas accès de me donner on
n'apprend pas les mêmes choses n'avaient
pas lui-même a priori non plus du coup
on arrive à des conclusions différentes
mais c'est pas grave c'est les points
parisiens ce qui compte c'est est ce que
j'ai fait le au mieux pour savoir si
justement que possible c'est pas est-ce
qu'on est tombés d'accord sur la même
chose il ya d'autres désaccords
notamment avec thibaut désaccord sur le
réalisme sur est ce qu'il existe une
réalité et donc pour beaucoup la science
c'est un peu la découverte ou
l'exploration de cette réalité
moi j'ai l'impression que si on suit
littéralement les équations de la
formule de baisers et des probabilités
c'est pas du tout ça qui nous intéresse
ce qui compte c'est de savoir quel est
le degré de crédence accablant on peut
faire confiance à différentes théories
eu égard au fait qu'elle soit vraie ou
non c'est pas parce qu'une théorie est
fausse que l est pas utile et cette
citation que sortent souvent tous les
modèles sont faux certains sont utiles
on a pas mal disserter là dessus avec
tivo et moi je pense vraiment que c'est
une phrase importante qu'il faut leur
que vraiment toutes les théories faut
considérer qu'elles sont fausses et que
certaines sont utiles
thibault est pas d'accord parce qu'il
pense qu'il ya des currys vrai que la
quête des théories vrai reste une fin en
soi quelque chose de très souhaitable
d'accord ni thibout est pas complètement
bas et bien disons que en tout cas sur
la manière de structurer la connaissance
il ajoute des axiomes qui me semble pas
feint qui sont clairement pas des
axiomes bayésiens et il trouve ça
important de l'art ajouté alors que il
me semble qu'un bel 20 se restreint ou à
yanis moutons rien on en parle avec le
toit dans cinq ans correspondrait devenu
corps évolué ouais bah tiens en parlant
du futur du coup comment est ce que tu
vois le futur de la recherche en
économie
j'en sais rien je suis passé je suis pas
assez proche des milieux académiques
pour savoir le peu truc enfin ce que je
souhaiterais en tout cas je peux dire ce
que je souhaiterais la manière de vivre
avec ça évolue je pense qu'il faut
beaucoup plus de d'interdisciplinarité
entre les économistes
et particulièrement en ce moment les
mecs qui s'occupe de la science du
climat
je crois qu'il me manque clairement de
une passerelle ici à être ré même les
physiciens les géologues les économistes
pensent que parce que moi ce que
j'identifie comme étant le gros problème
qui nous arrive dessus c'est c'est notre
impact sur l'environnement
voilà c'est pour moi c'est le alors il
ya évidemment je suis moins bercé enfin
je connais moins les histoires
d'intelligence artificielle mais enfin
j'ai bien compris dans tes vidéos que ça
pourrait aussi être les noms me prends
un improbable un énorme problème il faut
vraiment donc là pour le coup peut-être
qu'il faut aussi des jets
j'ai du mal à fin autant autant côté
intelligence artificielle j'ai
l'impression que ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'il y ait de la recherche liée à
comment rendre les ja bénéfique autant
du côté du réchauffement climatique j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut carrément
repenser tout notre toute notre
organisation en fait c'est il faut
repenser le capitalisme et là ça me
paraît être une tâche il s'agit pas
juste de libérer un peu d'argent pour la
recherche pour qu'il ya certaines
personnes qui dit ok voilà les
techniques à mettre en place parce que
même si on arrivait à détecter les
techniques à mettre en place après le
fait de les mettre en place ce serait un
truc absolument qui impacterait la vie
de tout le monde
je ne sais pas si au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
quelque chose qui serait aussi profond
donc voila et en plus de ça j'ai
l'impression qu'on se dirige pas du tout
vers le bon chemin donc en termes de
choix enfin jeu j'y pense aux problèmes
environnementaux en général et il y en a
plusieurs
compacité scana en particulier pas plus
puisque les ressources les ressources
finies est-ce que c'est plus les
changements le changement climatique le
réchauffement est ce que c'est des
points de sécheresse liés au changement
climatique géant présent j'ai
l'impression que c'est un mélange à la
fois là le fait de m'être intéressé
beaucoup aux problèmes pétroliers ça me
fait me dire que si on prend un pic
pétrolier en demain quoi on va se manger
une récession
dans la tête qui va nous faire qu'est-ce
que ça amènerait parce qu'aujourd'hui
les récessions qu'on a eu
tu vois par exemple la crise de 2008 la
crise des subprimes et tous étaient
malgré tout une crise financière alors
il ya certains ingénieurs certains
chercheurs qui font le lien entre les
premières formes de contrainte
énergétique et la crise de 2008
je sais que jean marc jancovici en
parler dit que l'europe et est entré
dans une phase de contraintes des
ressources à partir de 2006 à peu près
et que derrière il ya une crise
économique et où donc lui il fait il
fait la passerelle entre les deux voilà
où j'ai un peu plus de mal à voir ça
comme ça c'est ben étant donné que
l'europe est une
donc l'idée c'est 50 à moins de tam en
énergie donc si tu as moins d'énergie tu
peux faire moins de travail si tu fais
moins de travail et on économise
développement etc etc et donc forcément
quand à une contrainte dans ton flux
d'énergie bat à une contrainte
économique qui fait qu'on n'arrive plus
à faire qu'on va faire augmenter ton
pays mais alors le problème de ça c'est
que il ya le l'économie c'est compliqué
le pib s'est compliqué et il n'y a pas
que des marchandises dans le pib il ya
aussi des services
il ya aussi des services qui sont
valorisés enfin dont la valeur peut
dépendre des bulles financières et des
bulles spéculatives
donc tu peux avoir une croissance de son
pib boostés parce que l'idée c'est que
imagine que les prix de l'immobilier
augmentent pas ça veut dire que les
agents immobiliers qui prennent une
commission à chaque fois qu'ils aient
une vente il gagne de plus en plus
d'argent
cet argent là il l'est dans le pib
pareil pour les financiers les traders
qui surf sur une les traders qui servent
sur une bulle spéculative financière
prélèvent une partie de cette fausse
valeur entre guillemets puisque c'est
une bulle spéculative par le biais des
bonus et de leurs salaires et donc du
coup ça ça c'est intégré dans le pays
des donc du coup tu t'es trop ton pib il
a l'impression qu'il va grossir alors
que normalement le pib est supposé
mesure est une création de richesse
la tête et tu vois tu étais agents
immobiliers ils font toujours dit
transactions par mois par exemple
simplement une transaction sont
tellement plus énorme que tu valorise
plus fortement ce service alors que le
service a potentiellement pas bougé il
ya toujours le même nombre de
transactions pour exactement les mêmes
donc le pib mesure c'est tous les biais
du pib qui mesure pas forcément très
bien la croissance économique et donc le
fait de dire quand il ya un flux
restreint d'énergie il ya forcément
moins de pib c'est pas nécessairement
évident d'autant plus qu' il peut très
bien y avoir des usines qui sont
délocalisés en chine
si bien que le flux énergétiques en fait
il n'est pas contraint en europe mais
simplement il y en a moins besoin parce
que c'est en chine qui en a plus besoin
et puis on remplace sa part des formes
de services qui vont etc etc
tout ça est il de dire que le pib c'est
finalement le flux monétaires de
l'économie réelle c'est le flux
monétaires de l'économie mais en plus
c'est pas forcément une description
correct parce que tu vois comme je t'ai
expliqué c'est pas que le flux
monétaires de l'économie réelle c'est
aussi les flux monétaires de tous les
services connectés aux économies pas
réel ouais et la saison compliquée hélas
hélas l attitude donc je sais qu'il ya
des chercheurs qui essayent de justement
de se dire de prendre le pib uniquement
comme création de richesses et d'enlever
toutes les parties du pib qui
correspondent pas à une vraie création
de richesses mais qui correspond à une
inflation dans une augmentation des prix
dans des sphères comme la sphère
financière ou la sphère immobilière donc
le service rendu est le même mais parce
que les produits mobiles et coûte plus
cher on a l'impression que le service à
créer plus de richesses alors qu'en fait
non je trouve ça intéressant parce que
tu dis du coup faire croître les flux
monétaires comme tu veux dire là c'est
pas très clairement un truc positif pour
la société
pourquoi est-ce que croître ses fils
monétaire alors le c'est l'idée de la
part de gâteau à faire croître les flux
monétaires c'est aussi faire croître les
revenus
c'est faire croître les salaires en que
c'est pas les salaires puisque les
revenus c'est plus large que ça mais
c'est faire croître les revenus donc
l'idée c'est
tout le monde toujours plus pour tout le
monde toujours plus pour tout le monde
c'est un peu aussi le enfin maison bref
pour revenir sur cette histoire de
contraintes énergétiques
si demain on avait un véritable problème
sur le pétrole par exemple ça veut dire
le pétrole ça veut dire moins de
transport voilà concrètement ça veut
dire çà - transports mais comment se
matérialise à cette nouvelle répartition
des transports c est ce que ça tout
frais un pays par un pays j'aurais y
aurait un pays qui d'un coup il y aurait
50 % transport en moins ou est-ce que ce
serait tout le monde courait 0,01 %
transport en moins est ce que ce serait
bien ou pas comment est ce que parce que
moins de transport si d'un coup ça
touche le france port de marchandises
par exemple ça veut peut-être dire qu'on
aurait moins de fringues en europe
bon au moins deux téléphones portables
bon tu vois ça
mais si ça touche le transport routier
et que ça veut dire que paris est moins
bien approvisionnées par exemple en
nourriture ah ouais c'est pas pareil si
ça te paraît si ça touche l'agriculture
c'est des agriculteurs qui arrivent plus
à faire le plein de leur tracteur
ah oui c'est pas ça va pas être pareil
du tout comment on va gérer cette
contrainte sur le flux énergétiques donc
non seulement c'est sûr qu'il y aura un
impact économique derrière parce que si
on produit moins de boue ou contre on
produit moins de téléphone il y aura
moins de pib donc ça c'est sûr mais
c'est pas le même impact si on produit
moins de téléphone et si on produit
moins de bouffe et donc ça ça c'est
ça c'est un truc j'ai aucune idée et ça
me semble être potentiellement même plus
proche que les effets du réchauffement
climatique
qu'est ce cumul mais mais je sais qu'en
plus de cela pour les histoires de
réchauffement climatique il ya des
problèmes de ducey ya déjà des
écosystèmes qui vont changer petit à
petit au fur à mesure que tu l'aies que
tu optes tutu applique de la pression
c'est l'idée d'un genre de roseaux quoi
qu'il va plier petit à petit à petit à
petit à petit donc tu vas voir les
changements dans l'environnement
au fur et à mesure que tu appliques de
la pression et puis tu as là l'idée du
chêne où tu appliques de la pression tu
vois rien et d'un coup paf ça casse d'un
coup et là ça te fait un changement
terrible de d'un conteneur et il ya des
écosystèmes comme ça et d'autres qui
sont plus comme le roseau qui vont plier
on voit le changement
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
potentiellement d'état d'écosystèmes on
dit bon pour l'instant ça va
et qui pourrait changer du jour au
lendemain tu penses que tu disais sur le
cours du pétrole est fait qu'il soit
très peu prévisible et que le ouais
ouais bien sûr alors ça ça c'est un
énorme ça me paraît un élan problèmes
aussi cette histoire de prix d alors des
matières premières en général je prends
l'exemple du pétrole mais des matières
premières en général ne sait pas dire le
on sait que ce pétrole est un souci mais
on n'arrive pas comme la seule manière
d'essayer de sortir du pétrole c'est de
laisser le libéralisme faire son oeuvre
c'est à dire les entreprises sont libres
de choisir le consommateur est libre de
choisir tant qu'il n'y a pas un
indicateur prix important qui va essayer
de motiver les gens à sortir des
produits fabriqués à base de pétrole ou
les entreprises de d'essayer de se
libérer de l'emprise du pétrole a priori
tu verras pas de réaction est donc le
fait d'avoir des marchés qui sont pas
capables de transmettre cette
problématique de prix enfin c'est cette
cette ressource qui devient de plus en
plus rare n'est pas transmise dans le
prix c'est un vrai souci quoi alors que
pourtant le mécanisme s'explique très
bien ça on est capable d'expliquer
pourquoi on ne transmet pas pourquoi
dans le prix on ne voit pas la rareté de
la ressource mais on continue de penser
que dans le prix il y à la rareté de la
ressource que le prix correspond à la
rareté la ressource rare c'est pas vrai
et ça donc ça pose un problème en plus
de ça derrière sur ma potentiellement
les matières premières le d'autres types
de matières premières qui sont pas
forcément énergétique par exemple par
exemple alors peut-être pas l'acier je
suis pas un expert mais des tas de deux
de métaux rares dont on va avoir besoin
pour telle ou telle technologie qui sont
pas nécessairement c'est pas que ça
s'épuise
c'est juste que c'est moins concentrés
en fait tu vas être obligé de dépenser
avant on trouve un gramme dans dix kilos
maintenant ses appuis un gramme dans 100
kg puis un gramme dans une tonne puis un
gramme dans 10 tonnes
le problème c'est que pour récupérer un
gramme de 10 tonnes tu as besoin de
beaucoup beaucoup plus d'énergie que
pour récupérer un gramme dans dix kilos
donc forcément le problème énergétique
s'applique à ça aussi c'est à dire si on
veut fabriquer plus d'éoliennes plus de
panneaux solaires mais que pour
fabriquer ces éoliennes il faut des
métaux qui sont de plus en plus
difficiles à trouver et donc il faut de
plus en plus d'énergie pour aller
chercher est ce qu'à un moment donné
c'est pas le serpent qui se mord la
queue et on n'arrive pas à fabriquer
suffisamment d'énergie pour femmes pour
four pour aller chercher les métaux qui
nous servirait à créer l'énergie dont on
a besoin tu vois dont on a besoin
bon tout ça j'ai l'impression que ça
commence à se mettre en place
et voilà aimé mais il n'en sais rien
j'ai aucune idée des des horizons de
temps dont on parle pour le pétrole ça a
l'air d'être quand même un truc est
assez qui arrive rien que le fait de
voir de plusieurs décennies enfin de
quelques décennies plus tôt en fait le
truc c'est que le pétrole conventionnel
donc le pétrole conventionnel c'est de
pétrole qui sort de l'arabie saoudite en
gros quoi c'est un pétrole assez liquide
qui permet de faire un peu tout à la
fois en pétrochimie mais aussi des
carburants et fioul kérosène diesel
ce pétrole là et il semblerait bien
qu'on ait déjà tapé le pic serre que
depuis 2004 à peu près ça fluctue mais
la tendance
elle est assez flat on extrait toujours
la même quantité ce qui augmente c'est
les pétroles lourds très lourds très
lourds et lourds donc canada les roches
de l'alberta et sert là et le pétrole de
schiste notamment avec les états unis
qui est redevenue le premier producteur
mondial de pétrole
et le truc c'est que ces deux pétroles
là on peut pas les utiliser de la même
manière par exemple je lisais un truc
essayez de médecins dans une vidéo où
les il ya uniquement 26% du pétrole
américain qui est qu'on peut envoyer
directement qu'on peut envoyer dans les
raffineries
parce qu'en fait les raffineries
américaines elles sont conçues pour
produire ce que les américains ceux dont
les l'économie américaine a besoin
donc évidemment il ya tout le domaine de
la pétrochimie les plastiques des
engrais etc
mais il faut aussi beaucoup de carburant
eh ben le pétrole de schiste on peut pas
faire du carburant avec il faut le
mélanger avec un pétrole plus lourd pour
faire du carburant donc les américains
en plein de pétrole mais ça ne
correspond pas à leurs usages y en a que
26 % qui correspond à leurs visages ils
sont obligés d'acheter des pétroles plus
lourd au mexique au vénézuela et au
canada notamment pour mélanger ça avec
leur pétrole léger pour faire un truc
qui correspond à leur raffinerie qui
derrière va pouvoir le reproduire tout
ce dont ils ont besoin
donc le fait d'avoir ce pétrole
conventionnel qui va peut-être se mettre
à chuter tout en sachant que derrière
ces pétroles donc
lourd ou extrêmement léger c'est
beaucoup plus énergivore pour aller les
chercher
et là tu as un autre problème c'est te
dire bah ça paraît rien comme ça mais si
je te dis que j'ai besoin de 15%
tu sors un baril de pétrole sur ce baril
j'en ai besoin de 15% à réinjecter dans
les machines pour te sortir le baril
d'après ça veut dire qu'en gros 15% de
l'économie sert à aller chercher le
pétrole
et ça c'est en train d'augmenter cela on
passe de 15 à 16 17 20 25 % jara
aujourd'hui on est encore à très faibles
ondées genre à 2% tu vois qu'il sert à
aller chercher l'énergie
mais si demain on était à 20% pour aller
chercher l'énergie et si on a le pétrole
conventionnel qui se met à chuter c'est
clairement ce qui va se passer d'un coup
parce que les deux autres types de
pétrole non conventionnel coûte très
cher en énergie allez allez trouver tu
te retrouves avec une économie qui ne
fonctionne plus que pour aller chercher
de l'énergie où un quart des efforts de
ton économies servent à aller chercher
de l'énergie
ça laisse plus beaucoup de place pour
tout le reste toute la diversité de tout
ce qu'on fait à côté tout noter que les
super complexe elle est notamment lié au
fait qu'on n'a pas besoin qu un bon on
n'a pas besoin de trop se préoccuper de
l'énergie il suffit de mettre 2 % de nos
efforts et on récupère tout ce dont on a
besoin
si d'un coup il fallait mettre un quart
de nos efforts pour récupérer tout ce
dont on avait besoin
ah bah là ce serait plus du tout pas et
qu il y aura beaucoup moins de médecins
de deux chercheurs je sais pas il ya
plein de trucs qui disparaîtrait alors
ça pourrait peut-être résoudre en partie
près du chômage font râler mais tout le
monde à aller chercher du pétrole quoi
ouais
et ça par rapport à d'autres problèmes
je pars pas en parler pour elle
l'augmentation de l'inégalité est ce que
tu penses que c'est un problème pour le
futur je pense que c'est alors je pense
que c'est un énorme problème parce que
encore une fois si tu vas dans le situe
si tu restes dans l'aspect du hockey la
croissance elle est essentiellement
physique c'est à dire que la croissance
des richesses reste lié très fortement à
une croissance des marchandises et donc
ses marchandises
elle nécessite de l'énergie elle
nécessite des ressources ces ressources
ont fini donc on peut pas croître
indéfiniment comme ça un moment donné il
va falloir stagner
si tu stagne la question principale
devient comment je répartis les
richesses au sein de la population
donc là clairement temps il faut
attaquer ton problème d'inégalité ce que
pour l'instant la la solution pour
résoudre le problème des inégalités
c'est on va continuer la croissance et
on va tirer les pauvres vers le haut en
même temps qu'on tire les régies vers le
haut on tire tout le monde vers le haut
quand tu peut plus tirer quand quand est
rendu au point où tu as atteint un
plafond pour tirer quelqu'un vers le
haut il faut pousser quelqu'un d'autre
vers le bas pour compenser hélas la
tatin le vrai problème des inégalités
pour moi il ya un vrai problème de
répartition
je pense qu'il ya un vrai problème de
répartition des richesses on en revient
à cette histoire du marché je ne vois
pas pourquoi le marché serait un outil
parfait pour déterminer qui mérite quoi
je pense qu'il faut y mettre plus de
raisonnement que simplement le marché
plus d'intelligence et de cerveaux que
simplement de marché et il faut réussir
à re répartir correctement les richesses
alors du coup on va faire un petit peu
des jeux de paris pour essayer de
comparer les problèmes quel point tu es
confiant aussi par rapport à ton
optimisme si je prends un problème le
dit on des ressources environnement
général
et si je me prête en 2030
comment tu vois la chose probablement
vers hockey 2030
2030 cédant 11 ans donc eu alors je
dirais que au niveau du pétrole on
devrait commencer à le voir fortement se
dessiner alors je l'imaginent de deux
manières soit je l'imaginent part ça
devient beaucoup plus difficile
d'augmenter la la production voire même
on stagne un peu au niveau de la
production
donc ça se ressent dans l'économie etc
soit on augmente la production mais ça
coûte de plus en plus d'énergie ces
histoires du taux de retour énergétique
que je te dise ça je le vois de manière
quand même assez probable l'un ou
l'autre je dois mettre un pourcentage
ouais voilà j'en sais rien mais irait
peut-être 70% après il ya tellement
d'autres possibilités tu vois les il ya
toujours on va dire ouais mais on les
nouvelles technologies les voitures et
tous alors si jamais c'est pas cette
histoire du pétrole et consorts du
pétrole et que d'un coup la voiture
électrique fait un bond ou quelque chose
comme ça dans ce cas je vois un énorme
problème avec le charbon
et donc les émissions de co2 une
augmentation importante des émissions de
co2 parce que le charbon
si on remplace le pétrole par le charbon
c'est vraiment la méga merde c'est pire
pour le co2 c'est faudrait c'est pire
donc donc là si on fait ça je vois un
gros soucis moi je vois il ya une
continuité des émissions de co2 je vois
pas que ça j'ai pas l'impression que ça
a ses limites
je pense que dans dix ans on sera encore
en train de se dire ah là là on fait
rien extraits ces pessimistes et du cul
ouais moi je dirais qu'il ya bien ouais
il ya bien 60 70 % de chance même pour
qu'on continue à rien faire et les
inégalités dans dix ans tu précédent
tu vois c'est comment est-ce que ça
devient un gros problème critique alors
là il ya un truc il ya un truc c'est que
en fait la croissance des inégalités
donc je pense thomas piketty avait
montré j'avais lu son et du son livre il
ça fait un moment maintenant avait
montré que grosso modo si je me souviens
bien le mouvement c'est croissance des
inégalités depuis le début du
capitalisme en gros jusqu'au jusqu'à la
première deuxième guerre mondiale fin
mai jusqu'à la deuxième guerre mondiale
en fait les guerres à chaque fois ça ça
ça remet un peu les compteurs à zéro
ça fait un peu ça et donc la seconde
guerre mondiale avait fait un peu ça et
et depuis on a eu une croissance encore
des inégalités depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale à peu près 1 je dirais que
c'est ça le mouvement que j'ai retenue
donc le fait est que ce qui me semble
avoir fonctionné dans la deuxième moitié
du xxème siècle c'est plus l'idée de la
croissance qui tirent les pauvres qui
sort les pauvres de la pauvreté mais qui
enrichit les riches encore plus riches
qui ne sort les pauvres de la pauvreté
et donc du coup il ya une augmentation
des inégalités et le truc c'est que à
cause de ses problèmes énergétiques et à
cause du fait qu' on va peut-être
essayer de quand même combattre les
émissions de co2 et tout est le fait que
l'on trouve de moins en moins de pétrole
peut être probablement qu'on bloque au
niveau de la croissance économique
si bien que le mécanisme de on sort les
pauvres de la pauvreté commence à
s'arrêter
ça tape un peu un genre de maximum
notamment dans les démocraties modernes
que sont les nôtres genre la france le
royaume-uni l'espagne les états unis etc
et donc tu commences à avoir des
mouvements un peu sociaux qui disent oh
là là mais ce qui se passe là on en
profite plus alors que du coup les seuls
capables de bien s'en sortir avec le peu
de croissance qu on s et ceux qui sont
déjà au sommet serre que on retrouve
cette inégalité normalement quand on
quand il ya 10 à manger les riches
prennent 7
et puis il reste trois pour les pauvres
et puis quand il n'y a plus que 5 à
manger c'est les riches qui prennent 5
ils prennent tout inclus rien pour les
autres ou alors ils prennent vraiment la
majorité donc j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
peut-être un retournement la politique
qui pourrait amener à une meilleure
répartition des richesses
je pense que d'ici 2030 y on aura fait
quelque chose que pour que quelque chose
se serait passé je sais pas ouais je je
je pense je pense alors après leur essai
1 quelle probabilité
ouais je sais pas je n'étais pas m je
dirais je dirais que je suis peut-être
un peu moins sûr là je mettrais 50 50 50
non plus plus 60 un peu plus que la
moitié parce que moi je m'imagine quand
même que ça va ça va gueuler
suffisamment pour que les politiques
changer un peu quelque chose c'est pas
évident entre entre la masse qui peut
potentiellement être dans la rue et on
sait bien les élites qui sont plutôt
connecter à des gens qui ont des
intérêts il s'accorde pas avec ceux qui
sortent dans la rue
forcément bon allez réduction des
inégalités 60% de chances qu est ce que
tu as d'autres prennent pour 2030
par exemple ce que tu penses de la
polarisation idéologique est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui inquiète tu veux
dire les laisons les gens qui sont de
plus en plus où ils gagnent retranchés
dans leur avec des idées peut-être plus
extrêmes qu'avant alors j'aimerais bien
j'aime bien je sais pas s'il ya vraiment
des études là dessus qu'ils arrivent à
chiffrer un peu ce truc là
est ce que c'est c'est crédible est ce
que c'est il ya pas mal d'études enfin
quelques études aux états unis qui
montrent que les typiquement les si on
regarde le proportion la proportion de
républicains qui pensent que les
démocrates sont un danger pour la
démocratie pour les états unis où
montent beaucoup et vice versa
pourcentage de démocrates qui pensent
qu'eric plus qu'un sont un danger il ya
dix ans c'était moi je dirais chiffre un
peu au pif mais enfin de mémoire plus
tôt mais faut 30% et puis là se monte à
70%
donc moi je pense que ça s'est vraiment
lié à des problèmes économiques
c'est la croissance il ya plus de
croissance comme comme on laisse comme
on l'avait avant du coup il ya une
espèce de volonté de trouver un coupable
enfin même pas de trouver un coupable
probablement de faire quelque chose
serra les gens y pensent ils disent bon
ben ok il ya un souci donc faut agir
alors après c est ce qu on identifie
bien le problème est est-ce qu'on agit
correctement est-ce qu'on agit sur les
bancs ce qu'on va pousser les bons
boutons ou est-ce qu'on se trompe
donc moi je pense que ça c'est lié
probablement alors si ça continue bah
ouais ouais je vois une potentiellement
une montée à à moins qu'il y ait un
mécanisme efficace qui soit mis en avant
pour essayer de de montrer aux gens qui
a quand même probablement beaucoup moins
de chance que ce soit les juifs où que
ce soit plutôt que ce soit un problème
d'énergie un problème de voilà à moins
qu'on arrive à faire ça et ça
m'étonnerait pas que cueillez de la
montée des hooligans isme et du coup
tout apparaît d'appuyer sur des boutons
est ce que tu question d'après toi les
meilleurs leviers d'action qui on est
aujourd'hui pour que ça se passe bien
voilà les questions difficiles à
arracher que ge a été étudiée c'est la
dernière après les gars qui sont
difficiles j'aime bien ton id de youtube
et de l'algorithme le fait de bien que
l'algorithme pour essayer de recommander
des des vidéos qui disons que je pense
que ce serait pas mal de faire ça c'est
à dire d'essayer d'identifier le
problème en parlant à différents
spécialistes d'arriver à quantifier en
disant ok visiblement il ya quand même
70 % des spécialistes qui semble dire
que le problème c'est le réchauffement
climatique x % qui pensent que c'est
plutôt sa tante % et ensuite les vidéos
qui correspondent à chaque sont pondérés
de cette manière là par l'algorithme
donc 70% de mes vidéos recommandés sont
sur le climat parce que 70% des gens
pensent que enfin son nid pour cent des
spécialistes pensent que c'est
effectivement ça le problème
voire pourquoi pas un truc comme ça de
pondération l'algorithme je sais bien qu
éthiquement c'est quand même pas très
très démocratique et tout mais
je sais pas si ce serait pas quand même
une bonne solution ensuite ensuite des
leviers alors juste pour revenir c'est
cet algorithme enfin des trucs que je
voyais en fait davantage c'est c'est
plus informations déjà à l'esprit
critique un diamant recommander des
vidéos conspirationnistes très clivante
très très énervé on va dire et peut-être
remplacer sa part des vidéos sur le
climat mais peut-être même avant
d'arriver aux cuma ou des prénoms
environnementaux prennent des digues
étaient tous à d'abord des trucs sur par
exemple esprit critique raisonnée mieux
raisonner d'ivoire vidéo d'hygiène
mentale ne serait ce serait des vidéos
que j'aimerais que j'aimerais que les
jeunes sont allés plus de vue que ces
vidéos sur des montages reconduit alors
ok je dirais que du coup en allant dans
ce sens là il ya un gros truc à faire
sur l'éducation donc mais donc
potentiellement la manière dont on va
enseigner à l'école les sciences les
connaissances d'une manière générale il
me semble que ça c'est pas forcément une
très bonne idée parce que si on se dit
que les problèmes à venir là c'est pour
la prochaine décennie ou deux prochaines
décennies
les gens qui sont à l'école aujourd'hui
basse en supposant qu'il n'arrive
vraiment bien exercera tous à ce qu'ils
méritaient de gagner
et qu'en plus on arrive à ce qu'ils
continuent à bien réfléchir après après
coup ça restera comme encore une
minorité de la population
là pour le coup moi je rétorquerai à cet
argument que il ya beaucoup de clarens
qui apprennent par leurs enfants
ça c'est un très bon arrive aussi qu'ils
reviennent qui reviennent un peu aux
maths à la physique à l'histoire parce
qu'il ya les devoirs de la petite ou du
petit et que ou même que le tyran de
l'école et qui dit papa il faut pas
mettre la canette dans la poubelle
oui et tu vois les gens sont un peu
happé par leur part leur métier et ils
n'ont pas le temps de regarder de la
vulgarisation forcément et c'est après
par leurs enfants qui reviennent un peu
à ce genre de choses donc je pense quand
même que l'éducation a peut-être un rôle
à jouer
c'est ceux ci servent aussi à une autre
réflexion que je me fais de plus en plus
c'est le fait que chez les adultes
notamment les gens qui ont fait des
écoles de commerce ou d'ingénieurs vous
connais bien du coup en fait il je pense
que ces gens là beaucoup aimeraient
faire davantage pour pour toutes ces
causes et tout ça mais ouais ils ont un
boulot et il se voyait que sont france
ils font des heures
horrible puis à la fin de la journée bas
sont crevés c'est très difficile de
trouver le temps et alors que toi et moi
on a vraiment la chance mais d'avoir un
métier où en gros notre job c'est un peu
de réfléchir quoi du coup normal qu'on
réfléchisse à ces questions mais mais
c'est tellement difficile qu'on n'est
pas on n'a pas tout ce temps que j'ai du
mal à réussir à me dire que mon job
c'est de réfléchir j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir un job déjà passé mais ouais
ouais alors / - c'est vrai
et il n'empêche qu'il ya il ya il ya un
truc aussi que disait c'est jancovici
qui se trouvaient très intéressant c'est
la norme sociale
l'action par la norme sociale donc
l'idée c'est de dire on dit tout le
monde dit merci
c'est pas une loi mais tout le monde dit
merci c'est normal et donc il ya des
normes qui se met en place comme ça ou
non tu achètes pas un 4 4
c'est enfin et donc là je donne ou dans
ou tuent ou tu prends pas l'avion pour
aller en week-end quoi c ou tel en pour
une entreprise c'est inconcevable de
produire des bouteilles en plastique et
de pas faire la collecte des bouteilles
de verre enfin la consigne tu vois ce
genre de normes qui se met en place dans
la société ça je pense que ça peut être
un gros levier
le problème c'est qu'il me semble que
des normes comme ça ça met un temps fou
avant de passer dans la société avant de
passer dans le aimé j'ai aucune idée de
comment on pourrait renforcer l'adoption
de ce fait un pas que ça prend un temps
fou je dirais que c'est assez difficile
à prévoir parce que moi typiquement un
truc que j'observe
dans mon entourage au moins mais
l'impression que ça ça j'y arrive quand
même pas mal plus c'est le
végétarianisme que pour des raisons de
changement climatique
j'ai l'impression qu'au cours de la
dernière année on s'est juste même pour
des 360 derniers jours sur 365 derniers
jours j'ai eu pas mal de plus de gens
qui se sont tournés vers le père ce
genre de d'alimentation enfin regardez
sur les ventes de viande et c'est ce
qu'il ya une belle parce qu'il ya une
différence parce qu'il ya aussi le
problème moyenne
on connaît des gens qui regardent
clairement celle ci reste encore je
pense que c'est encore une bulle
qu'enfin cesse et les gens que je
connais mais voilà c'est c'est quand
même déjà intéressant je pense aussi
souvent au revenu universel qui a une
notion en 2014 2013 2014 quand j'étais
exposé à ça au début et que j'en parle
et ben ça semblait complètement utopique
à tout le monde et puis via finalement
pas si français est quand même en 2017
avec un candidat à la présidentielle qui
ont parlé quoi et c'est quelque chose du
genre à 2 j'aurais trouvé inimaginable
en 2014
c'est vrai ok on peut être mais j'ai
aucune idée c'est soyez donc c'est ce
que tu dis c'est très imprévisible quoi
difficile je comprends pas trop qu'est
ce qui marche pourquoi ça marche quand
est ce que ça marche
et après ben ouais j'en sais rien c'est
j'ai tendance à me dire que j'ai
tendance à me dire que malheureusement
si ce qui risque peut-être de se passer
mais c'est peut-être trop simpliste mais
je sais pas c'est que il va se passer un
gros truc moche un moment donné vraiment
moche et j'ai aucune idée de ce que et
que là d'un coup ça ça fait réagir tout
le monde autant dire que les gens ont
besoin d'un coup de poing sinon à coup
de pouce ni au droit
c'est un peu ça aurait peut-être je
pense qu'il ya une dimension très
émotionnel aussi c'est à dire tu vois il
ya un sait pas on va voir comment on
peut cliquer ça il se passe un truc un
peu un peu un peu spectaculaire les
médias en parlent les gens ça leur parle
ça alors tout juste qu'il ya une petite
fille qui a été par exemple je sais pas
quoi et donc du coup ça y est on a
touché à l'émotion parce qu'on a touché
à l'émotion là on a un levier d'action
qui est très fort alors quand naples est
forcément à l'intelligence du coup
naturellement il ya le côté bayésiens
qui a refait son de voilà qui arrive et
qui dit oui mais bon on n'est pas sûr
même temps il ya peut-être ça peut-être
ça l'avenir est imprévisible
alors que quand on appelle à l'émotion
c'est beaucoup plus fort ouais mais
c'est aussi beaucoup moins dit que ça va
faire des changements positifs ça je
trouve ça pas très rassurant ah bah moi
déjà parce que l'action donc tu
n'arrives pas à prévenir la catastrophe
qui qui fait bouger les choses et aussi
parce que derrière potentiellement la
réaction c'est du hooliganisme et ça va
être compliqué moi qui étais un autre
autre levier d'action
ils sont là comme ça je sais c'est pas
des trucs auxquels j'ai particulièrement
a réfléchi nous doit être un peu plus
sûrement plein de trucs et plein de
trucs que je auquel je pense pas
j'espère que
moi ça va faire réfléchir les gens je
pense que c'est une question importante
de réfléchir à qu'est-ce qu'on peut
questionner vraiment les vues le biais
d'actions et pas juste dire il faudrait
que alors un autre levée alors si un
autre levier d'action moi je mets donc
c'est éminemment complexe à mettre en
place et j'en suis tout à fait conscient
alors moi je dirais
il faut une restriction clair sur les
ressources matérielles qu'on a le droit
de consommer voilà donc ça veut dire qu'
il faudrait limite je pense qu'avant de
donner
rodolphe de leurs éveilleurs a dû
mentionner sa des quotas carbone
c'est-à-dire un moment donné à chaque
fois que tu consommes un truc paf ça
t'enlève il n'ya pas ta pâte à deux
portefeuilles tu as un portefeuille
monétaire un portefeuille carbone et
voilà tu as tout le tout le monde un
quota est donc ça veut dire que ce quota
évidemment il est alors il est
égalitaire dans le sens où il ne dépend
pas de tes revenus
donc voilà mais par contre il doit être
aussi égalitaire dans le sens tu à 5 ans
versus 13 55 ans t'as pas le même quota
carbone ou alors enfin tu vois forcément
en fonction des différentes moment de ta
vie tu vas pas avoir besoin de la même
chose si tu as des enfants pas des
enfants etc
donc c est éminemment complexe à mettre
en place mais je pense que c'est un truc
qui pourrait être réfléchie notamment en
lien avec des technologies qui existent
comme l'histoire de blocs chain et ses
côtés a plutôt créé taxe quotas ouais je
pense que ce serait pas mal taxes taxes
et vient taxes taxe carbone carrément
mais aussi un quota parce que le
problème
à un moment donné c'est d'être tu peux
utiliser les deux quoi le problème c'est
d'être capable de dire il faut que
notent nos émissions de co2 diminuent
donc à un moment donné à la fin de
l'année tu dis voilà on était là l'année
dernière il faut qu'on soit là cette
année là il ya un objectif et il s'agit
pas de dépasser donc à un moment donné
il faut une contrainte réelle et
alors ça malheureusement ces lycées très
liberticide à serques et ça tu as tu
veux acheter un deuxième et banon alors
ça on connaît pas ces inconnus à partir
du moment où thalys ou sur ton compte
normalement tu fais ce que tu veux
alors que là maintenant non c'est là en
plus de ça un portefeuille un nouveau
portefeuille qui vient se greffer et ça
je pense que ça peut très bien être
ça peut être assimilée de manière tout à
fait correct j'ai l'impression
à partir du moment où c'est géré de
façon égalitaire c'est à dire qu'on
commence pas à entendre parler d'un
bernard arnault qui s'est acheté trois
yachts et qui voyagent tous les jours en
hélicoptère qua non à partir du moment
où on a bien réussi à montrer que abane
en bas bernard arnault des foyers en
vélo ok mais pas évident ok on va
s'accomplir appelé les questions j'ai
deux dernières questions en fait à te
poser la question que je pose être monde
dans ce podcast la première c'est à ce
que tu peux essayer de tout
4 quel serait le message clé que tu
aimerais que les ce que les auditeurs
retiennent de ce podcast
ça fait trois heures qu'on discute
tu sais bien faire des synthèses de
relance était candidat j'y passe du
temps j'y passe un temps fou à savoir
exactement comment bien résumé le truc
hockey n'était pas obligé tout résumé
juste le message clef à retenir que dans
un message clair au taillan
ok alors un message clair à retenir si
je devais parler reprendre sur ces
histoires d'économies je dirais que ok
alors je résume le rsa avec money is
money sort de chez match et malgré un
une autre présentation de l'économie que
je trouve meilleur que ce que
j'utilisais avant donc y ait là là là la
clé la clé pour moi de vous du problème
ça reste les histoires énergétique les
histoires d'environnement et ses serres
l'homme évolue dans l'environnement donc
il faut absolument tenir compte de cet
environnement et on ne peut pas
dissocier les questions économiques de
ces questions environnementales elles
sont clés elles sont essentielles pour
forcément réussi réfléchir à ça ensuite
le deuxième truc c'est que la mécanique
économique
et financière c'est une espèce de cadre
au sein duquel l'homme évolue et que ce
cadre et il est tout à fait changeable
transforma l'on peut faire un peu ce
qu'on veut et donc sa force aussi
j'aimerais que les gens se posent des
questions sur la pertinence de
l'organisation politique qu'on a en ce
moment sans forcément essayer de se
demander si on devrait avoir une banque
centrale indépendante ou pas sans
forcément se demander de rentrer toutes
les contradictions technique simplement
se demander si ça leur paraît logique
que il se passe telle et telle chose
dans le monde qu' il y ait des gens qui
soient dehors ou pas où ils n'ont est ce
que c'est
est ce que c'est normal qui est des gens
qui soient très très très riche et
d'autres vraiment querrien oui non ce
genre de choses et de ne pas penser que
abbaoui évidemment je trouve ça pas
normal qu'ils aient des gens qui dorment
dehors
enfin en même temps c'est comme ça une
espèce de fatalisme de fatalité comme ça
que bah oui mais on peut pas faire mieux
j'aimerais que les gens se sortent ça de
la tête parce que moi je croyais ça
aussi on donnait et plus j'ai étudié le
truc plus plus je m'éloigne de cette
pensée gipa que l'utopie c'est possible
tout le monde qui court dans les champs
demain j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
c'est certain que iliad il ya des tas de
choses qui sont qui sont carrément
faisable et donc plus que de s'arrêter à
des dimensions techniques de la
réflexion c'est à dire de de dire à ce
serait bien s'il ya plus de gens dehors
et puis tout de suite après de dire oui
mais comment tu vas payer pour etc non
ça ça se gère ça c'est technique au
contraire je pense qu'il faut militer
pour enfin militer je pense qu'il faut
avoir des opinions sur des choses qui
sont justement simple au départ et après
l'essai au technicien la manière de
dépatouiller le problème est fort
probablement les techniciens trouveront
un moyen pour dépatouiller le problème
c'est pas à eux à la limite de se poser
trop ce genre de questions alors est-ce
que ça résume bien ce à peu près où j'en
suis dans la pensée en ce moment c'est
bien
est ce que je peux faire aussi deux
recommandations de vidéos de podcasts ou
de livres ou de personnes à suivre ou
tienne
eh ben deux vidéos de podcasts donc je
peux pas dire toi évidemment parce que
ce serait retrouve hockey et bien le
réveil heures voilà pour toutes les
questions environnementales et je dirais
donc leur est versé une chaîne youtube
pour ceux qui qui peut naître et hot
ouais voilà le réveil heures rodolphe
donc une chaîne youtube sur le
changement climatique est une chaîne
youtube un podcast
ils disent on est bien
ok donc l'âge et la dimension plus tôt
donc pour le bouquin je peux pas en
donner deux nazis alors je dirais pour
pour tout ce qui est pour tout ce qui
est technique de la mécanique économique
et/ou et bah je moi je recommande quand
même steve kean dating économique non il
ya un titre en français attend je crois
que s'appelle l'imposture économique
alors forcément ça comme ça ça a l'air
et c'est vrai il est critique mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est qui il
explique comment ça marche
et après il dit pourquoi il est pas
d'accord et donc c'est bien parce que
moi je trouve ça bien parce que d'abord
il explique comment ça marche dans le
détail donc c'est très dur à lire mais
au moins voilà si on est intéressé pour
savoir juste comment ça marche on peut
extraire que ça du tout et qui après on
n'est pas obligé de lire la critique
par exemple si on veut pas donc moi je
trouve que le livre est très bien et le
deuxième c'est un bouquin qui m'a été
recommandé par quelqu'un récemment qui
s'appelle la nouvelle raison du monde